Aurélien [musique] Barreau, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons dans le cadre d'une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Vous êtes astrophysicien et surtout vous
avez lancé un appel à l'aide et un appel
à contribution auprès de certaines
personnalités de si mes souvenirs sont
bon pour sauver l'écologie ou pour faire
prendre conscience du problème
écologique. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ?
Oui, donc je suis professeur à
l'université Grenoble, Alpe. Donc
j'enseigne un peu à tous les niveaux de
la licence à l'école doctorale, surtout
de la physique parce que c'est mon
métier, mais aussi un peu de philo parce
que j'aime ça. Et puis au niveau de la
recherche, bah je travaille sur les
trous noirs, le big bang, l'univers à
grande échelle, la gravité quantique,
enfin toutes ces choses qu'on comprend
pas très bien mais que je suis payé pour
qu'on essaie de comprendre un peu mieux.
Je suis pas sûr que ça marche, mais on
fait on fait ce qu'on peut. Et puis bah
en parallèle de tout ça, comme tout le
monde, je suis un être humain et donc
j'ai des convictions, j'ai des combats
et il y a des choses qui me paraissent
un peu plus importantes que d'autres. Et
donc je crois que de temps en temps bah
faut se retrousser un peu les manches
quoi, même si c'est un peu hors de notre
champ de compétence hein, parce que la
la tribune écolo qu'on va certainement
évoquer, finalement, j'ai aucune
légitimité scientifique pour m'embarquer
dans cette voie mais je m'en fous.
Peut-être votre compréhension des
mathématiques.
Ouais mais je pense que c'est marginal.
Théodore Mono que j'aime beaucoup qui
était à la fois un botaniste et un grand
marcheur du désert, un jour il s il il
s'est engagé à fond pour les animaux,
pour la sauvegarde de la planète, contre
la la la fuite en avant technocratique
et quelqu'un lui a demandé "Mais est-ce
que c'est bien votre compétence de
scientifique ?" Il a répondu "Non,
monsieur, c'est en tant qu'humain." Bah,
ça me parle.
Le l'appel
ça a raisonné et ça a fait vibrer auprès
de certaines personnalités. Est-ce que
c'est pas un éème appel
unème cri à l'aide pour l'écologie qui
va faire l'équivalent d'un d'un pai dans
un verre d'eau ?
Ah mais complètement, moi je suis
persuadé que ça va rien changer. Euh
bon, epsilon c'est mieux que zéro. Ce
qu'on appelle epsilon en math, c'est
quelque chose qui est tout petit, hein.
Euh j'y crois pas. J'ai pas le moindre
début d'embrayon d'espoir que grâce à
nous, le monde va être sauvé. Simplement
ne rien faire, c'est pire encore, quoi.
Voilà.
Pourquoi pas d'espoir ? Bah, pas
d'espoir parce que comme vous l'avez
dit, il y en a eu plein d'autres avant
euh dont un super appel de 15000
scientifiques vachement plus compétents
que moi qui a été mené à l'échelle
international avec zéro effet. Euh après
le nôtre, il y a eu 600 scientifiques
français qui on en publié un autre dans
l'Bay. Donc il y en a plein des appels.
On est un parmi une infinité avec des
effets qui sont pour l'instant nuls.
Donc c'est pas franchement encourageant.
Simplement on on utilise nos armes.
Voilà. Moi personnellement, j'ai pas de
kelashnikov chez moi. Donc mon arme
c'est ça, c'est d'essayer de parler
correctement. J'ai pas une médiatisation
très importante, mais elle est pas
complètement nulle non plus. Finalement,
aller parler des équations d'Einstein,
je continuerai à le faire, ça me plaît
bien. Peut-être qu'on en parlera tout à
l'heure. Mais là, il y a quand même un
truc un peu important, c'est la fin du
monde. Donc moi, ma toute petite
notoriété, si je peux la mettre au
service de ça, bah oui, c'est tellement
plus important que tout le reste que ne
pas le faire, ça serait juste idiot
finalement. Est-ce que vous pouvez
délayer c [rires] cette perception de
fin du monde ? Pourquoi vous
Ouais. Alors le terme fin du monde,
c'est vrai qu'il est un peu provocateur.
Bon strict auensus, voilà. Si on va être
complètement littéral, ça dépend ce
qu'on appelle le monde. Évidemment que
même si on fait les pires taloperies à
la surface de la planète, ce qui est
déjà en cours, la Terre va continuer de
tourner autour du soleil. Donc si je
prends ma casquette d'astrophysicien, le
monde il sera toujours là. Il y aura
toujours une planète tellélurique que
les Martiens, enfin les néomartiens pour
pouvront voir dans leur télescope. Donc
en ce sens-là, le monde demeure. Mais si
on est un tout petit peu sérieux, c'est
quoi le monde ? On s'en fout. Si la
Terre devient un gros caillou, elle a
plus aucun intérêt, plus aucune
spécificité, plus aucune légitimité.
Elle mérite pas qu'on se batte pour
elle. En fait, ce qui fait que la terre
est belle, ben c'est nous quoi. C'est
les vivants. En fait, c'est la grande
tribu des vivants. C'est le fait qu'on a
une diversité incroyable avec des
espèces qui résulte d'une histoire qui
est très longue et très scabreuse et
très fragile. C'est ça le monde. Si on
perd ça, moi j'ai pas peur d'appeler ça
la fin du monde et en ce moment, on est
en train de le perdre. Donc je crois que
c'est même pas être catastrophiste en
fait.
Pourquoi on est en train de le perdre ?
Pourquoi on perd cette singularité ?
Bah parce qu'on est très con. Euh ça
c'est c'est qui on nous et nous tous
c'est moi le premier hein. Je veux dire
le la grande la grand le grand ensemble
des humains euh se comporte comme aucune
autre espèce ne s'est jamais comportée
dans l'histoire de la Terre. On
reprétente 0,01 % de l'ensemble des
vivants actuellement et 85 % des morts
animales sur l'air industrielle sont d
aux humains. Donc c'est un effet de
prédation qui est totalement sans
équivalent euh dans l'histoire
planétaire, pas dans notre petite
histoire à nous, dans l'histoire totale
de la Terre depuis 5 milliards d'années.
Donc c'est une situation qui est d'une
gravité absolue. Voilà. Donc cette
gravité absolue euh on en parlera sans
doute. Moi j'ai pas de remet de miracle
pour la conjurer. Mais ce que je sais
c'est que si on continue comme ça, ben
on va pas continuer très longtemps.
Est-ce que c'est pas le la nature qui a
inventé l'homme parce que l'homme est la
meilleure façon de dissiper de l'énergie
?
Écoute, moi je suis pas croyant donc je
pense que c'est la nature qui a inventé
l'homme he pour moi. Il y a aucun doute
là-dessus. Après, je récuserai la vision
un peu finaliste quoi de dire bon on l'a
inventé à tel. Moi je crois pas qu'il y
a une téléologie comme ça. Donc le mot
pour dire qu'il y a une finalité, qu'on
soit tous orientés vers un but. Je crois
qu'il y a une évolution un peu
aléatoire, un peu stockastique. Le
vivant se forme et on est une espèce
parmi d'autres. En réalité du point de
vue biologique, on n pas du tout plus
achevé que nôre. On n'appelant pas au
sommet de la pyramide. Ça évidemment
c'est notre représentation super
anthropocentrée du point de vue purement
philogénétique, on est un philom plein
d'autres sans aucun primat. Alors, c'est
vrai que bon, on a quand même quelque
chose d'un peu particulier, c'est que on
a la capacité à détruire ce que nous
sommes et les autres en même temps que
nous. C'est pas complètement un détail.
La question est-ce qu'on veut le faire ?
Parce que franchement, si on parle de
capacité physique, on a aussi la
capacité de violer la prochaine personne
qu'on croise dans la rue si elle est pas
trop barraqué ou de tuer nos enfants. On
n pas franchement envie de le faire,
j'espère. Donc, il est évident au
quotidien qu'on ne fait pas tout ce
qu'on pourrait faire. Et la question qui
se pose avec la planète, c'est
exactement ça. On a la capacité de la
détruire. Est-ce qu'on veut le faire ?
Et peut-être l'argument que que vous
empruntiez ressemble à un argument qui
est un des sols en fait moi qui me fait
un peu vaciller chez les antécolos, on
va dire, qui est de dire finalement euh
vous êtes en train d'extraire l'homme de
la nature parce que tous les prédateurs
font des dégâts autour d'eux et donc en
demandant aux hommes d'essayer d'être
végétarien, peut-être on y reviendra,
d'essayer de un petit peu moins détruire
leur environnement. En fait, vous leur
demandez de renoncer à leur nature.
Donc, en fait, vous êtes les pires
anthropoccentristes, vous les écolos,
sans le savoir. Alors, cet argument, je
crois même que parfois, il est sincère
en fait chez les gens qui le donnent.
Donc moi, je le trouve pas idiot, mais
je crois qu'il est quand même
complètement faux parce que il
présuppose que exercer son être de
nature, c'est maximiser son impact
destructif sur l'environnement. Et ça,
c'est juste factuellement faux. C'est
exactement comme si on disait aux hommes
"Mais vous avez des bombes atomiques,
vous auriez dû déjà faire péter la
planète."
Personne n'est assez bête pour dire ça.
C'est pas parce qu'on les a qu'on doit
les utiliser. Et même les super
prédateurs, franchement les lions, on
s'amuse pas à écraser des fourmis, hein.
Je veux dire, donc personne ne prend
comme règle de vie de devoir faire le
maximum de dégâts possible. En fait,
vivre c'est faire des choix pour les
animaux comme pour nous. D'ailleurs, on
est des animaux. Donc il y a rien de
très étonnant à ce niveau-là. Et c'est
pas du tout nous extraire de notre
condition d'être naturel que de dire
sachant ce qu'on sait, quels sont les
choix qu'on a envie de faire comme
n'importe quel animal. Alors brièvement,
qu'est-ce qu'on sait ?
Alors, on sait que ça va très mal.
Voilà. Euh ça va très mal à plein de
niveaux différents. Je pense qu'on va
reparler du climat, mais j'ai envie de
pas commencer par le climat parce qu'on
en parle déjà beaucoup. Mais c'est pas
du tout le seul problème le climat. À
mon avis, c'est même pas le plus gros.
Actuellement, il y a un effondrement de
la biodiversité qui est incontestable.
Euh récemment, il y a quelques jours, il
y a une un très bon papier qui est sorti
de deux chercheurs au CNRS qui a fait
une métaanalyse sur 10000 articles
publiés. Bon, c'est très clair, il y a
aucun questionnement possible. Tout
s'effondre. Et là encore, faut être bien
subtil. Il y a un effondrement des
espèces, ce qui en soit est dramatique.
C'est-à-dire que
au rythme actuel, dans pas très très
longtemps, on va vraiment avoir une
extinction massive. On sait qu'on est en
cours de 6e extinction massive. Mais il
faut pas raisonner qu'en terme
d'espèces, faut aussi regarder les
individus. Et ce qui est presque plus
inquiétant encore, c'est que même dans
les espèces qui ne sont pas encore
menacées, il y en a quand même
quelques-unes, il [grognement] y a une
chute drastique des population.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, pour le dire
simplement, les vivants sur terre sont
tous en train de crever. Même les
espèces qui sont encore abondantes, les
les je sais pas les moineaux, enfin je
dis un peu au hasard.
Ouais, les moineaux, ils vont mal.
Ouais, c'est mais en fait ils vont un
peu tous mal. Tu vois, je dis les
espèces abondantes, ça me vient même pas
spontanément en fait. Bon, il doit y en
avoir quelques-unes.
Les connards [rires]
là, elle est en croissance. Ouais. et
ben euh il y a quand même une diminution
des populations quoi. Donc ça c'est
super inquiétant en fait. Et pour moi ça
a du sens parce que je trouve ça triste
de se dire pour les hommes, c'est les
individus qui comptent parce
qu'évidemment quand on perd euh la mort
d'un humain c'est toujours un drame mais
en revanche pour les animaux ce qui
compte c'est juste les espèces. Ça je
trouve que c'est un anthropocentrisme
qui me déplaît. Et je les animaux ont
aussi leur vie propre. Donc c'est triste
à la fois en tant que disparition
d'espèces et en tant que disparition des
individus. Ça c'est ce qui est en en
cours. Et la cause de ça aujourd'hui,
c'est pas le réchauffement climatique.
La cause de ça aujourd'hui pour la
principale cause, elle est parfaitement
connue, c'est la disparition des espaces
de vie. C'est qu'on est en train de
s'étaler partout en fait et que les
animaux n'ont simplement plus d'endroit
pour vivre. Ils n'ont plus de lieux pour
vivre. La le morcellement et l'atrophie
des lieux de vie fait qu'en fait bah il
meurt. Donc le premier truc dramatique,
c'est l'expansionnisme géographique de
l'espèce humaine qui fait que bah oui,
les autres forcément n'ont plus de
place. En fait, on n'arrive pas à ne pas
se rendre compte qu'un territoire dont
personne n'est propriétaire, il est pas
vierge, quoi. Il a beaucoup d'autres
occupants. Mais euh ça vient à l'esprit
de quasiment personne de se dire quand
je vais construire ma maison euh ou mon
usine, ce qui est pire, euh quels sont
les occupants que je vais détruire ? Se
pose même pas la question. Si on a le
l'acte de propriété, ben c'est bon quoi.
Donc ça c'est le premier point. Il y a
d'autres problèmes de biodiversité qui
sont bien connus. Par exemple, le fait
qu'on chasse et qu'on pêche maintenant
trop. la pêche industrielle a un impact
massif sur la perte de biodiversité. Il
y a le problème de la pollution, il y a
le problème des extinctions en chaîne.
C'est que les espèces sont
interdépendantes. Donc quand on en
flingue une, en fait, il y a il y a
toutes celles qui dépendent de celles-là
qui vont aussi se retrouver en
difficulté. Ça c'est un truc dramatique
qu'on sait. L'autre point effectivement,
c'est le réchauffement climatique.
Pourquoi on en parle plus que de que de
la perte de biodiversité ? parce que ça
a un effet plus direct sur l'homme. Non,
la perte des des cigales probablement va
pas mettre l'humanité en danger. Alors
que le réchauffement climatique a
davantage des faits directes sur les
hommes. Ça en a aussi sur les animaux
évidemment, mais ça en a plus
directement sur les hommes. Donc on en
parle beaucoup, tant mieux hein, parce
que c'est un vrai problème, c'est pas le
seul. Et là bah on sait que c'est
dramatique aussi. C'est-à-dire que en
fait
mes collègues scientifiques
climatologues sont parfois, c'est pas un
reproche, mais sont parfois trop prudent
parce que nous dans notre métier, moi je
peux me permettre de dire un peu
n'importe quoi là. Enfin, je crois que
je dis pas n'importe quoi mais je peux
le dire comme ça parce que c'est pas mon
métier donc je suis pas en train de
parler de ma recherche. Dès qu'on parle
de son métier, on est toujours très
pointilleux. Et en fait le problème des
vrais spécialistes, c'est que ils vont
toujours tempérer un peu. Ils veulent
être absolument sûr d'être
irréprochable. Donc ils vont avoir
tendance à revoir un peu à la baisse
leur manière d'estimer les impacts. Et
puis pour être un peu consensuel, pour
pas faire peur aux gens, pour pas se
fâcher, pour être audible,
pour pas pour pas flinguer sa carrière,
ça je sais pas, peut-être on on en
reparle, je suis pas sûr, mais ils vont
avoir tendance plutôt à minimiser le
truc mais en croyant bien faire hein,
c'est pas un mensonge, mais ils oublient
qu'ensuite ces résultats ils vont être
rediscutés avec les lobbyes, avec les
pouvoirs publics et cetera et donc ils
vont être encore amoindris et à la fin
il reste plus rien. Et aujourd'hui, ce
qu'on sait, c'est que la catastrophe,
elle est réelle. Il y a il y a plus
aucun doute là-dessus quand on regarde
les élévations de température, je veux
dire, il y a vraiment plus que Trump
pour en douter quoi.
Sidification des océans.
Voilà, n'importe quelle personne doué de
plus de deux neurones ne peut plus
remettre en cause ça. Ça relèverait du
négationnisme finalement et on on n pas
tellement envie de le faire en histoire.
On n pas non plus tellement envie de le
faire avec l'avenir. Et c'est en train
c'est ce qu'on fait. Nier aujourd'hui
cela et notre influence sur cela, c'est
faire un négationnisme du futur et non
pas du passé. Ce qui est tout aussi
dramatique. Moi, j'appelle ça un crime
contre l'avenir en fait. on on
s'interdit d'avoir un avenir. Voilà.
Alors le climat donc là aussi ça va
évidemment flinguer des espèces et des
individus animaux mais même au niveau
des humains là ça a un impact évidemment
direct. Alors il y a plein de pays, pas
de chance les pays pauvres he comme
toujours, qui vont être directement
touchés par ces élévations de
température ou simplement on peut plus
vivre. Là il y a eu des pointes en
Algérie cet été à 55 je crois 55° on
peut plus vivre hein. Je veux dire même
en buvant bien c'est pas possible. Alors
ce que la solution c'est te mettre de la
clime qui évidemment consomme beaucoup,
c'est ça va rendre les choses encore
pire. Donc c'est pas une solution
et et ça va avoir des effets indirects.
J'aurais juste donner un exemple parce
que je pense que celui-là tout le monde
le comprend. C'est le problème des
déplacements de population. Là en ce
moment on a des réfugiés syriens
on s'en occupe pas. Moi déjà à titre
humain là indépendamment de de l'aspect
écologique, je trouve ça honteux. On
laisse mourir des gens devant nos
frontières. On se dit accueillir 200000
personnes mais c'est pas possible, on y
survivrait pas. Ce qui évidemment est
complètement faux. En terme économique
et social, on pourrait parfaitement y
survivre. On sauvera leur vie, on
préfère les laisser mourir. Bon mais là,
on parle pas de 200000 personnes. Les
chiffres actuellement, c'est au minimum
2000 millions de réfugiés climatiques,
peut-être jusqu'à 1 milliard. Et c'est
pas dans 20 siècles, hein, c'est dans 30
ans. Et donc ça, ça ne peut pas ne pas
faire de guerre. Euh, on le voit bien,
personne ne va ouvrir ses frontières en
disant "Venez profitez de notre climat
tempéré. Donc on est en train de
préparer un monde où non seulement les
vivants seront en train de s'atrofier,
de s'étioler, mais en plus les
conséquences secondaires seront des
conflits entre les vivants qui restent.
Est-ce que c'est vraiment ça qu'on a
envie pour mes vieux jours ou la force
de l'âge de mes gamins ? Bah je vois pas
comment on peut le défendre quoi.
Alors la question bateau, pourquoi les
politiques n'agissent pas ? On a bien
notre petite idée mais on va vous
laisser développer.
Alors pourquoi ils n'agissent pas ?
Alors ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
l'excuse du on ne savait pas n'est plus
tenable. Bon il ils l'ont employé
pendant un certain temps, ce qui ce qui
est faux en réalité. Il y a 30 ans, on
savait déjà. Mais si on avait envie de
faire semblant de ne pas savoir, ça
était possible dans le passé. Dans le
présent, c'est beaucoup plus difficile.
En fait, je j'ai même pas envie de faire
porter la responsabilité que aux
politiques parce que en réalité, si la
population le désirait fortement, il
serait bien obligé de suivre.
Finalement, ils veulent être élu. Donc
si on votait pour ceux qui proposent ça,
et ben euh ceci euh aurait lieu. Donc
euh ils sont le reflet de notre
faiblesse en fait. Et notre faiblesse,
c'est que finalement renoncer à un peu
de confort nous est quasiment
insupportable. Et ça c'est quand même
assez délirant en fait quand on y pense.
Je pense que c'est à la fois
probablement un endoctrinement des
valeurs dans lesquelles on vit qui ont
qui ont valorisé qui qui ont quand même
capitalistique clairement. Et puis c'est
peut-être aussi un peu effectivement un
tropisme quand même de ce que nous
sommes quoi, parce que euh à l'époque
des chasseurs cuueilleurs, il y avait
déjà un impact considérable de l'homme
sur la nature avec une extinction qui
systématique de la macrophone dès que
une zone de la planète était colonisée.
Donc moi, je crois qu'il faut le but là,
l'enjeu qu'on a face à nous, c'est pas
de revenir à un passé fantasmé qui a
jamais existé où on aurait été en
équilibre avec une nature bienheureuse.
Je crois que ça n'a jamais été le cas en
fait. faut vraiment inventer un avenir
radicalement autre. Donc c'est un truc
extraordinairement difficile et euh ça
n'en prend pas du tout le le chemin hein
puisque en ce moment tous les vœux sont
des vœux pieux. Euh euh en France on a
signé des accords pour la réduction euh
d'émission de gaz carboné. L'année
suivante ça augmentait. Donc je veux
dire même un an après, on n'a pas été
capable d'appliquer euh l'accord qui
était que nous avions, je crois en
partie initiée. Donc c'est une tartue
frite. Voilà. Là, les gens disent
n'importe quoi, font n'importe quoi, par
payer payer avec notre argent.
Voilà. Et
et donc je pense que voilà, ce terme est
à la mode, mais faut peut-être qu'on
soit un peu les lanceurs d'alerte quoi,
de cette catastrophe qui aujourd'hui
n'est même plus vraiment cachée quand
même.
On a les on a les politiques qu'on
mérite.
Je le crains. Ouais.
Qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
faire un séisme intellectuel au sein de
la population ? J'ai une question
d'internet qui vient d'arriver. Face à
l'inxistence de la réaction politique
sur l'urgence climatique, seriez-vous
prêt à utiliser la violence pour faire
avancer les choses de manière plus
rapide et efficace ? Si oui, comment
utiliser la violence ? Ça c'est une
question super intéressante.
L'armée des 12 singes
parce que Ouais parce que Non mais le
problème de la violence c'est qu'il y a
aussi une construction culturelle de la
violence. C'est-à-dire que euh quelqu'un
qui effectivement te casse la gueule, tu
dis c'est un acte de violence euh
insupportable. Mais en revanche, le fait
de laisser crever, comme c'est le cas en
ce moment un enfant toutes les 6
secondes euh de faim alors que
concrètement on aurait complètement les
moyens matériels de subvenir à ça, c'est
pas considéré comme un acte de violence.
Bah c'est comme ça, c'est le destin,
c'est inévitable. Quand un McDo est
saccagé dans une dans une manifestation,
je crois de mémoire que le ministre a
dit que c'était un acte inqualifiable.
Inqualifiable. Donc ça veut dire que
c'est vraiment le sommet puisqueon ne
peut même pas le qualifier tellement il
est horrible. Donc il n'y a rien de pire
que cet acte là. Alors que en effet ce
que fait Mcdo en Amazonnie où on a on
déforeste de façon inconsidérée le
poumon du monde bah ça c'est normal.
C'est donc donc c'est pour ça qu' la
question de savoir est-ce qu'on serait
prêt à recourir à la violence. Elle est
déjà intéressante parce que elle demande
d'interroger ce qu'est la violence.
Alors, si on parle violence au sens
banal, quoi, au sens violence physique
ou vraiment action militante, choc hors
la loi et cetera, euh je sais pas, moi
je j'ai un peu peur de ça pour une
raison euh purement
attention, la fichesse arrive, hein.
Quoi ?
Attention, votre fichesse arrive.
Oui, voilà, exactement. Mais non,
justement, il arrive pas parce que là,
je vais me dégonfler et je vais pas
répondre oui. Oui, je ne vais pas
répondre oui à la violence en fait parce
que j'y crois pas trop. Parce que il y a
eu mes 68 par exemple, on vient de le
célébrer là. Enfin, c'est vrai M68.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a vu ? En fait, on a vu
des gens qui ont effectivement bougé les
JDU et puis juste après, le bon peuple
de France qui a voté très à droite pour
qu'on mette fin à cette espèce de de
petite bulle d'oxygène. En fait, ça fait
peur
derrière Macron. Non.
Ouais. Bon, mais Conit maintenant, il a
plus grand chose à voir avec ce qu'il a
été. Je sais même pas vraiment ce qu'il
a été d'ailleurs. Moi j'ai j'ai pas vécu
ça. Mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
il y a un effet il y a un effet quand
même pervers de ça, c'est que ça fait
peur à tort ou à raison. Mais ça fait
peur. Et cette peur là, elle peut
[grognement] vraiment être
contre-productive. Donc moi, je
préférais quand même faire peur avec une
violence qui est plus pacifique qui est
de dire "Mais plus jamais on votera pour
vous". Quoi ? Moi, j'ai les 200
personnes que qu'on a fait signer la
pétition.
Euh
bah donc c'est avec Juliette Binoche
l'actrice que j'ai fait ça. Il y a il y
a Pedro Almodevar, il y a Catherine Deu
enfin c'est il y a des star il y a aussi
plein de membres de l'Académie des
Sciences du Collège de France, il y a
[grognement] Bellatar le réalisateur et
cetera. Bon et puis bon, il y a Alain
Delon, je le fais exprès d'en parler
parce que tout le monde m'a allumé
là-dessus. Ça a posé plein de problèmes
qu' est Alain Delont dans la liste. Ben
moi, je suis très content en fait parce
que Alain Delont, bon je connais pas du
tout ses convictions, je l'ai jamais
rencontré mais enfin dans ma tête
c'était quelqu'un qui était à droite. Il
aime
pas les migrants.
Bon c'est c'est l'image que j'avais. euh
bah voir que quelqu'un que je suppose
être de droite accepte en fait de signer
un texte dans lequel on dit en substance
que toute politique qui n'est pas
aujourd'hui prioritairement écologique
n'a plus de sens. Alors soit il a pas lu
le texte, bon ça je là je veux pas
savoir. Mais s'il croit vraiment ce à
quoi il a signé, moi je trouve que c'est
une nouvelle. On est en train de dire
aux gens même des gens qui sont plutôt
de droite, qui sont plutôt
conservateurs, enfin je crois, je le
connais pas personnellement, sont en
train de se rendre compte qu'en fait
toute politique qui n'est pas prièrement
prioritairement écologique n'est plus
éligible. Ben si en fait il a lu et
qu'il croit vraiment ce qu'il dit, euh
c'est super important en fait. Et et
donc c'est ça pour moi le message, c'est
de dire maintenant euh on peut plus se
contenter de green washing, de beaux
discours, la main sur le cœur, les
larmes aux yeux et je me moque même pas
de Hulo parce que je pense vraiment
qu'il a fait ce qu'il a pu mais je pense
plutôt à son successeur. Euh il va
falloir euh se battre quoi contre les
lobby qui va fallir que eux se battent
contre les lobby qui prennent des des
mesures fortes, efficaces et réelles et
que nous on le leur impose. Bon alors et
pour l'instant moi j'avoue que j'imagine
pas tellement agir autrement qu'en
parlant ou qu'en votant. Bon je suis pas
sûr que des action commando franchement
ça jourait pour
donc la violence et la force des faibles
et commence où s'arrête les
connaissances. On est d'accord là-dessus
probablement.
On est d'accord là-dessus. Si je te dis
euh si on peut se tutoyer euh les
politiques n'ont aucun intérêt à court
terme à faire un sevrage énergétique sur
les populations parce que il risque
beaucoup trop gros par rapport à la vind
dicte de la population qui a été
endoctrinée dans une idéologie
capitaliste d'hyperconsommation.
Et si je te dis que les systèmes
bancaires et économiques overstretch
hypertendu n'a aucun intérêt à ralentir
parce que il va se retrouver comme
quelqu'un avec la marée basse,
c'est-à-dire en short.
À court terme, le politique a très peur
de ça et préfère une fuite en avant,
soit par le déni, soit par
le fait de de d'imaginer une solution à
moyen terme, c'estd après moi le déluge.
[grognement] Euh qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour cette ce transfert de connaissance
auprès des populations ? On a on a on
leur fait des cours d'écologie à
l'école. On envoie Juliet de Binoche en
maillot de bain en le disant que voilà,
il va faire tellement chaud queon sera
tous en maillot de bain. Je déconne.
Mais des préconisations par rapport à ça
pour endurcir le cerveau des
populations.
Oui. Alors, je suis d'accord avec ce que
tu dis. Euh peut-être à ce détail près
que je pense que le système capitaliste
a plein de de problèmes, de défauts. Il
y a aussi quelques vertus à mon avis
d'ailleurs. Mais là en l'occurrence, je
suis vraiment pas sûr que ce soit la le
principal problème parce que
on a voulu pour de bonnes ou de mauvaise
raison mais peu importe, il y a une
mesure là de passer la vitesse sur
nationale de 90 à 80 km/h. C'était
peut-être pour gagner de l'argent avec
les amendes. J'en sais rien à dire vrai.
Moi je trouve ça plutôt bien. À la fin
ça fera moins de mort, ça pollue moins.
Et ça suscitait une levée de bouclier.
Dire aux gens, vous allez devoir rouler
10 km/h de moins en bagnole, mais
c'était insupportable. Moi, j'ai vu sur
les réseaux sociaux, les gens pétaient
les plombs, quoi. On allait réduire leur
vitesse de croisière de 10 km/h mais
c'était une atteinte aux libertés
fondamentales qui leur était
insupportable. Ça je c'est même pas
c'est pas capitaliste ça. C'est c'est
une espèce de fondamental qui fait que
on a quand même en nous cette espèce de
désir absolu comme ça d'aller d'aller au
bout quoi. Et là en fait on va tellement
au bout queon se rapproche du mur et du
gouffre à une vitesse vertigineuse.
Alors tu as complètement raison. À court
terme, quelqu'un qui prendrait ces
mesures là serait mal vu, non seulement
par sa population et mettrait même son
pays en difficulté dans la compétition
mondiale parce que comme tout est
mondialisé, si la France ralentit son
économie euh oui, elle se fragilise par
rapport aux autres. Donc je n'ai pas de
solution miracle, c'est hyper dur et je
suis pas très optimiste. Mais simplement
ce que je crois moi c'est ça, c'est que
à l'échelle individuelle c'est
impossible. Si on dit simplement aux
gens, vous savez en rouler à 80 km/h
c'est mieux mais qu'il y a pas la loi.
Mais personne le fera et moi je le ferai
pas. Donc je suis sûr que ça la
responsabilité de tout un chacun sur la
moi j'ai beaucoup cette remarque après
l'appel en me disant vous devriez pas
appeler aux politiques, vous devriez
appeler au changement des attitudes
individuelles. Mais OK, j'y appelle mais
n'empêche que ça changera rien.
J'appelle au changement des attitudes
individuelles. Voilà, aujourd'hui
solennellement je le dis, polluer tous
moins, manger moins de viande. Voilà, je
le dis. Mais ça ça va avoir zéro effet,
j'en suis persuadé. Et donc je pense que
on a inventé un truc qui est la
politique euh pour le meilleur et pour
le pire. Mais le meilleur c'est que
justement c'est ce qui fait que quand on
est trop faible pour se limiter par
rapport à certains types d'actions, on
invente le politique et le juridique qui
sont là pour nous dire ça, tu as envie
de le faire, tant pis, tu le feras pas.
Tu le feras pas parce que ça a trop
d'impact sur le bien commun. Et c'est là
précisément où les politiques doivent
prendre leur responsabilité. C'est leur
rôle. S'ils font pas ça, ils ne servent
à rien. Ils sont là pour nous dire "Vous
avez envie de faire ça ?" Bah tant pis,
nous on vous dit non. Bien sûr que c'est
un peu infantilisant. Bien sûr dans un
monde idéal. Moi, j'ai même eu un peu
parfois des des ouais des proximités
intellectuelles, anarchistes et cetera.
Donc tout [grognement] ça, c'est
complètement contre ça. Mais tant pis,
là, il s'agit de sauver le monde et moi
j'ai pas d'autre solution que celle-là.
On revient au communisme, à une
dictature, une dictature verte, on fait
quoi ?
Dictature du prolétariat. Non, non, non.
Bien sûr que non parce qu'en fait je
pense que c'est l'inverse. Je pense que
ces mesures apparaîtront comme
liberticide sur le moment parce qu'on va
dire effectivement à des gens bah là
vous je sais pas vous déplacez trop ça
ça a un impact qui est tellement grand
que il va falloir vous déplacer un peu
moins ou alors vous pouvez pas mettre la
clime à fond alors qu'il fait quand même
que 24. votre santé est pas en danger,
vous êtes pas une vieille personne en
train de vous déditrater, bah donc tant
pis, mettez pas la clime. Donc
évidemment ça, on le ressentirait comme
une privation de liberté, mais c'est
comme un gamin auquel on interdit de
casser son jouet quoi. Sur le coup,
c'est une privation de liberté mais ça
va lui permettre de jouer avec pendant
toute son adolescence. Et moi,
j'aimerais que ce soit ça qui se passe,
que cette privation de liberté, on se
rende compte au bout de quelques années
qu'en réalité d'abord ça sauvegarde
notre jouet qui est le monde dans lequel
on n on est. Et puis que même en
déployant un rapport apaisé avec le
reste du vivant, avec ce que je préfère
appeler la nature que l'environnement,
l'environnement c'est ce qu'il y a
autour de nous, c'est encore vachement
trop centré. Et ben en fait, ça nous
donnera beaucoup plus de liberté, je
crois, en fait. Et donc l'autre
problème, parce que l'autre question
qu'on disait avant, c'était de dire bon
ça c'est pour militer pour que les
politiques le fassent. Mais après,
imaginons que demain notre président euh
mais passé l'après-midi là à nous
écouter, il se disent "Bah oui, oui,
oui, voilà, je vais le faire."
Forcément, la France va perdre de points
de croissance, hein, parce que faut pas
faire de langue de bois. Euh euh la
préoccupation écologique est
incompatible avec une croissance
économique exponentielle et continuelle.
He faut le le développement durable où
tout va bien en même temps, ça n'existe
pas. Donc, on va perdre de la croissance
suivant les indicateurs parce que
suivant d'autres indicateurs, on va en
gagner. Mais suivant les indicateurs
institutionnels, macroéconomique,
actuel, on va en perdre. Donc la France
sera en difficulté par rapport aux
autres pays. Il y a il y a quoi ? Tu te
rends compte ce que tu leur don ?
Il y a 150 pays dans le monde. Non, un
truc comme ça. C'est pas énorme quand
même. Bon, moins de 200 je pense. Bon,
c'est c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
10000 quand même. Ces gens-là se
retrouvent aux Nations Unies, ils ont
été élus. C'est censé quand même mettre
l'élite intellectuelle. Et ben, il faut
que ces gens-là trouvent une solution.
Déjà discuter avec un politique, l'élite
intellectuelle. Non mais arrête,
j'ai bien le droit de faire un peu le
naïf. Non, ça sert mon propos. Bon,
c'est un argument rétorique.
Je vais je vais je vais te poser une
question. On va essayer de de d'étendre
le débat. On est dans un phénomène de
sevrage, d'addiction à la calorie. Pour
résumer trivialement les choses.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe quand on met
quelqu'un en sevrage ? Une révolte.
H
Est-ce qu'on est prêt à affronter cette
révolte ?
Bah, ça sera difficile de l'affronter
parce que en fait, je pense qu'elle
n'aura lieu que si on la génère
nous-même. C'est-à-dire que ça peut pas
se faire complètement contre
l'assentiment populaire. Sinon, en
effet, s'il y a des des mesures qui sont
prises radicalement contre l'assentiment
populaire, euh oui, ça sera la révolte
et donc et donc et donc ça va pas se
faire en fait parce que personne ne
prendra ce risque. Donc c'est c'est là
où il faut faut qu'on joue sur le moi
mon seul espoir, mais peut-être il est
utopique hein, mais j'en trouve pas
d'autres en fait. Je me raccroche à ce
que je peux. C'est de dire on est des
raisonnables à l'échelle individuel mais
on est quand même assez raisonnable pour
dire oui, il faut que quelque chose me
régule. Si on n'est pas capable de faire
même ce petit pas qui est d'appeler pour
un régulateur global, alors je pense
qu'on est vraiment foutu. Je je vois pas
de solution. Je je sais pas comment on
peut faire.
Comment tu tu modélises ce foutu ?
Alors ça c'est une question qui est
aussi super intéressante parce que il y
a même des gens qui se disent finalement
ça serait pas plus mal.
C'est c'est ça ça se termine et puis
après reset et la vie reprend ses
droits. Bon, c'est un peu triste quand
même. C'est un peu triste pour tout le
monde parce que ça c'est une vision
purement en terme
global lointain quoi. On comptabilise le
nombre d'espèces sur la Terre et
effectivement même s'il y a une
catastrophe écologique majeure, il est
très vraisemblable que dans 50 millions
d'années, il y aura à nouveau un grand
nombre d'espèces parce que parce que ça
va recommencer. Même avec les déchets
nucléaires.
Ah oui oui. Si on prend des échelles de
temps suffisamment longues, je pense
même avec les échets nucléaires. Oui.
Mais mais enfin pourquoi alors à ce
moment-là, autant se suicider tout de
suite. Je veux dire ce ce notre raison
d'être c'est quand même d'essayer de de
s'accrocher un petit peu à à la beauté
qui est quoi. Voilà, on si c'est
simplement faire un paris sur les sur le
sur une on efface tout et on recommence.
Oui, on peut le dire. Mais ça c'est
quand même très niliste finalement. Moi
ça me motive pas tellement. Et puis
quand même faut pas oublier que c'est on
n'est pas des nombres, on est des gens
quoi. Si euh si demain ça a lieu ce
cette montée en température drastique et
cetera, mais gamin ils vont peut-être
crever pour de vrai quoi. Si c'est pas
si ça va avoir lieu.
Ouais. Ouais. Cit sur le drastique le si
mais je suis d'accord même le drastique
ça va avoir lieu. Là qui a deux fois
moins d'hommes en tant que tel, je m'en
fous moi si c'est juste le chiffre. Mais
après ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
c'est ces hommes qui vont qui vont qui
vont disparaître, ils vont mourir. Ils
vont mourir comment ? En agonisant, en
souffrant. Donc je veux dire, c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est
terrible quoi. Moi j'ai pas envie de ça.
Qu'est-ce que tu peux répondre à ceux
qui peuvent t'objecter que la science et
la technologie va nous sauver ? Ah
ouais, ça je l'entends un peu dans mon
milieu puisque je suis entouré de
scientifique l'étant moi-même. Euh et
ben moi j'y crois pas une seconde. Alors
le problème c'est que comme c'est un
paris sur l'avenir, c'est dur d'avoir
des arguments très forts là-dessus. Moi,
ça me paraît complètement délirant en
fait. Voilà, je pense pas un instant. En
fait, je pense que ça sera même pire que
tout parce que si on commence à vouloir
aller essayer d'envoyer des panneaux
solaires pour comme que les gens y
pensent he pour essayer de favoriser des
pluies à certains endroits et cetera, là
on est complètement au-delà de nos
moyens. Et puis même il y a il y a
quelque chose alors je voudrais jeis pas
le dire de façon religieuse he parce
qu'une fois de plus moi même je suis pas
croyant maisque
presque. Ouais et puis de la la
profanation quand même d'un truc qui est
un peu sacré. Pour moi, c'est pas Dieu
hein qui est sacré je sais pas ce que
c'est Dieu mais c'est quand même c'est
la fragilité de ce qui s'est mis en
place. En fait, à chaque fois qu'on l'a
fait, on s'est planté. On a inventé des
trucs très bien. Je suis ravi qu'il y a
des vaccins et je suis ravi qu'il y a
des antibiotiques. Je dis pas que toute
production humaine est à jeter. Bon, ça
c'est des choses très rationnelles sur
des problèmes très concrets
véritablement personne ne chope enfin
bon les vaccins un petit peu mais enfin
globalement c'est quand même assez
consensuel. Voilà quand on commence à
jouer aux apprentis sorciers bien on va
droit dans le mur. Quand on réintroduit
des espèces à la main pour contracter
autres espèces ça marche jamais.
on crée des des espèces envahissantes et
cetera et en réalité ça nuit à la
biodiversité.
Un collègue physicien des des corde
disait que probablement le le finalement
le seul espoir ça sera d'aller sur Mars.
Ah moi je trouve cette idée terrifiante
parce que d'abord je pense que c'est pas
vrai. En terme technique, on aura pas du
tout les moyens de le faire. Donc
premièrement je pense que c'est
peut-être une petite élite
concrètement faux. Et voilà. Et le
deuxième point que j'allais dire, c'est
que quand bien même on pourrait le
faire, c'est sûr que ça va pas concerner
grand monde. Donc ça sera vraiment, il y
aura les happy few mais qui seront très
très très fus et les autres crèveront.
Et puis les animaux évidemment, ça sera
quoi ? On prend fera quoi ? L'arge de
Noé, on prendra un couple de chaque et
le reste mourra lentement. Non non,
c'est c'est ça ça n'a aucun sens. Et en
plus, je veux dire, Mars n'est pas
habitable. Et là, on est en train de se
demander, enfin certains se demandent
comment faire du terraforming, c'estàd
transformer Mars en un lieu habitable.
Mais [__] on a une planète habitable,
c'est la nôtre. Donc on va peut-être
quand même commencer par sauver celle-là
avant de se demander comment on va aller
en en coloniser une autre. Ça a aucun
sens.
Comment générer un un bouclier
magnétique sur Mars, c'est ça ?
Ouais. Non mais les les en tant
qu'expérience de pensée, je trouve ça
plutôt marrant en fait. Mais en tant
qu'expérience de pensée, on va pas le
faire.
Alors question d'internet aujourd'hui
peut-on mettre des noms sur les ennemis
du climat ? Nous.
Ah franchement, moi je je je dis
publiquement que je me considère pas du
tout comme exemplaire, hein. Donc plus
le temps passe, plus j'essaie quand même
d'être un tout petit peu en accord avec
mes principes parce que parce que sinon
ça devient ridicule. Mais moi, je me
poserai carrément pas comme exemple
hein. Donc on est tous les ennemis du
climat. Bon là, j'ai donné un exemple
qui m'est favorable parce que j'ai dit
non, mais parfois je dis oui hein, que
ce soit clair. J'ai été invité il y a
quelques jours pour aller faire un
exposé
au Canada, pas un truc entre super
spécialiste ou peut-être je seraiis un
des seuls au monde à savoir faire parce
que c'est plus de mon domaine de
recherche. Non non, c'était de la
vulgarisation pour parler à des gamins.
Ça durait 10 minutes. Première classe.
Non, quand même pas première classe mais
à la limite la pollution est presque la
même. Donc on m'a proposé de faire quoi
? 15000 km aller-retour pour aller
parler 10 minutes à des gamins au
Québec. C'est complètement délirant.
L'invitation était très gentille he ça
partait d'un bon sentiment puis j'ai
sans doute était flatté en recevant le
mail. J'ai quand même dit non.
Heureusement j'ai été il y a quelques
jours après la pétition, il y a une
chaîne de télé qui me contacte. On va
faire une interview. Je dis c'est long.
Non non c'est pas long. Je dis bah on le
fait en Skype. Je dis non la la la
qualité est pas assez bonne. Je dis si
la qualité est assez bonne on s'en fout
de ma tête. Si on voit pas bien mes
cheveux, ça changera rien au message.
J'ai un réseau filiaire au labo, je peux
faire l'interview en Skype ? La réponse
a été non. Donc il fallait que je fasse
euh j'oublie pour de vrai, j'ai oublié
fallait peut-être me revenir, j'ai
réellement oublié mais c'était pas TF1,
enfin c'était pas un truc très connu. Et
euh donc il fallait que je fasse 1500 km
pour expliquer que il fallait amoindrir
notre notre rôle dans les transports,
enfin notre utilisation des transports.
C'est un peu paradoxal quand même. Donc
on est Oui, bien sûr qu'on est tous
fossifs. Alors les noms, les pires euh
bah c'est sûr que toutes les circuits de
grande distribution ont une influence.
Là, je pense qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui par exemple, moi je trouve
bon je porte je jette pas la pierre au
aux gens qui ont pas de sous hein et qui
peuvent pas faire autrement mais les
gens comme moi qui sont pas pauvres qui
vont chez Carrefour non quoi. Ah moi je
gagne pas mal hein. Professeur première
classe plus membre de l'Institut
universitaire de France a dû me donner
des primes. Je dois gagner pas loin de
4000 € par mois.
Net.
Ouais peut-être un peu moins. Mais je
veux dire c'est c'est confortable hein.
Moi je
c'est pas France 24 la chaîne de télé.
Non non non. France 24 justement on l'a
fait par Skype et donc voilà. Moi, je
suis carrément pas pauvre. Les gens
comme moi qui vont chez Carrefour euh ça
me choque. Voilà. Après, les ceux qui
peuvent pas faire autrement, j'ai rien à
dire. Mais je pense quand même que
effectivement il y a il y a il y a des
choses assez faciles quand même qu'on
peut faire pour redonner un peu de sens
quoi. Pour redonner un peu de sens et
pour que quand même du coup, il y a même
je trouve après c'est pas un effort, ça
devient un plaisir en fait, que
n'importe quel geste devienne un peu
militant, que tu demandes un peu ce
qu'il y a derrière. Euh bon, moi je dis
pas que que ça m'arrive jamais de
prendre un Coca en passant parce que
parce que parce que j'aime bien le goût,
hein. Je veux dire, bon, on peut pas
demander non plus la perfection parce
que la la beauté de la vie, c'est aussi
un peu d'incohérence et puis de temps en
temps, voilà, quand tu marches, tucrases
des fourmis et puis j'en sais rien,
peut-être que en ce moment à un moment,
je veux dire un truc qui va t'agacer ou
au contraire tu vas m'attaquer. Bon,
c'est la vie ça. Il y a des moments où
c'est pas agréable, on a un impact sur
les autres. C'est pas réservé à des
bobos si tu le
Ah oui. Alors ça, on me l'a déjà dit
plein de fois. Alors moi je suis
carrément un bobo, he je veux dire
concrètement effectivement une
sensibilité de gauche en gagnant bien sa
vie c'est un peu un toello, c'est
exactement l'archétype de ce qu'on
appelle un bobo. Bon moi j'avoue que je
déteste pas les bobos parce que en fait
bobo pour moi ça veut dire ça veut dire
je jouis d'un certain confort et pour
autant je me rends compte qu'il y a un
problème. C'est-à-dire que
et tu donnes des leçons aux autres.
Ouais, ça c'est le côté moins moins
reluisant. C'est vrai. Mais moi ce que
j'essaie c'est de donner les sons aux
autres et à moi-même en fait. Voilà.
Est-ce que tu peux dire à quelqu'un qui
est en précarité financière dans un
logement à précarité énergétique qui
arrive pas à chauffer, qui arrive pas à
bouffer autre chose que des hydrates de
carbone saturé produit à l'arrache qui
but des outant au fin fond de la forêt.
Euh
bah non, moi je lui dirai rien. Moi ça
c'est clair. Je peux pas faire ça force
vive pour les politiques
que c'est exactement comme le problème
de la démographie parce que il y a quand
même un problème de la démographie. Moi
personnellement, j'irai jamais dans un
pays pauvre où la seule richesse, entre
guillemets qu'ils ont, c'est de faire
des gamins, euh refaire un
néocolonialisme N +1 et leur dire "Voilà
les mecs, comment il faut les femmes,
voilà comment il faut gérer votre
population quoi." Donc ça c'est vrai que
là, il y a une tension mais en fait une
vision maltusienne de la démographie,
je sais pas mais bon mais en fait la
démographie peut-être que j'ai tort
parce que il y a des gens très
intelligents qui disent le contraire
mais j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit
un si gros problème que ça. On peut pas
avoir une croissance infinie dans un
monde fini, ça c'est sûr, mais on n'est
pas du tout en croissance exponentielle
en fait hein. Je veux dire, la
démographie,
elle est en train de se stabiliser. Donc
je pense qu'elle va se stabiliser autour
de 12 milliards. Moi, c'est c'est
franchement je je crois que c'est vrai.
C'est trop. Moi, je préférais qu'on soit
trois fois moins. Je pense que ça serait
mieux pour la planète. Mais si on
répartit un peu mieux les richesses,
je pense que 12 milliards qui se
comportent correctement, ça aura
beaucoup moins d'effet que 8 milliards
qui se comportent comme des salot.
Si si on répartit les richesses sans
avoir un cap. Ah oui ! Non mais si on
continue comme ça en est 12 milliards,
c'est la catastrophe ça. Il y a aucun
doute.
Question d'internet. Le discours
écologiste prend-il prend-il dans les
pays surpeuplés d'Asie ?
Alors alors moi j'ai pas une vision
globale là-dessus parce que parce que
c'est pas ma spécialité mais quelque
part j'ai moins peur de la Chine que des
États-Unis hein parce que je pense que
les alors le régime chinois actuel
est assez intéressant en fait. C'est
vraiment un mélange d'autoritarisme et
en même temps de pragmatisme et en même
temps de sagesse aussi un peu parce que
non
à Taïwan ouais c'est un peu la Chine.
Tu as juste étudié le confusionisme sur
É quoi ?
Non, j'ai eu plein j'ai eu des étudiants
qui venaient de Chine en fait et c'est
eux qui m'ont qui m'ont appris un peu la
Chine. Ouais peut-être. Ouais. Non c'est
des gens géniaux. Moi je j'ai été
souvent géné.
Ouais peut-être. Ouais écoute tant pis
hein. Et donc tout ça pour dire que j'ai
quand même l'impression que les Chinois
finalement ils sont assez pragmatiques.
Eux ils ont compris qu'ils avaient pas
le choix. s'ils font pas un effort
environnemental drastique, alors eux ils
vont vraiment ouvrir en premier parce
que les villes de Chine en ce moment, il
y a un taux de pollution qui est juste
invivable. Donc je et puis les Chinois,
ils ont ce côté quand même un peu
autoritaire quoi pour la démographie. Ça
a été géré euh dur avec des effets
catastrophiques hein. D'ailleurs, il y a
du coup un enfant par famille donc du
coup il y a plein de bébés filles qui
ont été tués parce qu'il préfèrent enfin
ça n'a je suis pas du tout en train de
dire qu'il faut faire partout pareil. Ce
que je dis simplement c'est que
concrètement je pense que quand ils ont
un problème à régler, ils le règlent.
pas forcément pour le meilleur mais
c'est pas ceux qui me font le plus peur
en matière de
de capacité à intégrer les faits. En
fait, je pense qu'ils ont une espèce de
factualité comme ça pratique qui fait
que ça va être géré. Je pense qu'en Inde
aux États-Unis c'est pas un pays en voie
de développement mais c'est un très gros
pollower et peut-être prochainement en
Afrique ça va être beaucoup plus
compliqué. Question d'internet.
Des entreprises comme Coca-Cola, Danon
culpabilisent les consommateurs avec des
slogans de type "L'écologie est une
affaire de tous. Est-ce que le combat
écologique ne devrait pas commencer par
le démantellement de ces grosses
industries ?"
Bon, il y a plein de niveaux d'action
pour moi. Pour le commencer, je pense
qu'il faut commencer assez simplement le
combat écologique. Moi, je commencerai
pas par là. Commencer un, c'est
consommer moins. Donc, OK, les gens
disent "ça politique, c'est de
l'initiative individuelle." Moi je crois
que ça doit être politique.
Tu tu sais ce qui se passe quand on
consomme moins.
Non.
Le système financier se vautre.
Tant pis pour lui,
mais on se vautre avec.
On a inventé un système politique. Bon
qui est censé, j'ai dit
censé être quand même indépendant et il
faut qu'il le prouve. s'il le prouve pas
euh c'est qu'il y a un problème.
Après, il faut quand même améliorer
l'efficacité énergétique. Par exemple,
le le c'est ça a l'air tout con, hein,
mais le l'efficacité énergétique des
bâtiments en France, ça fera des
économies monstrueux si on si on si on
isolait mieux thermiquement les
bâtiments. Euh et puis ensuite, il faut
changer de mode de production d'énergie.
Washing ça ? Bah, je l'ai cru mais il se
trouve que j'ai un collègue physicien
enquel j'ai énormément confiance qui a
travaillé sur la question, Freddy
Bouchet qui est membre du comité
national du CNRS qui est quelqu'un pour
qui j'ai une très très haute estime
intellectuelle et euh il a étudié la
question d'assez près et il semble qu'en
terme vraiment de calories quoi. Euh
c'est c'est vraiment un très gros
chantier. Donc bon, c'est pas mon
domaine mais j'ai confiance en des gens
qui considèrent que c'est pas du
washing, que c'est un truc sérieux.
D'autres truc si je te dis si je te dis
tu vas arrêter de nous faire du green
washing avec l'isolation de tes
bâtiments, tu vas expliquer aux gens
qu'il faut mettre un pull. avec un petit
bonnet, tu sais, un peu comme dans les
yaourts au fin fond de la la Sibérie.
On va faire des tout de suite et puis
avec une pression sur le biotop qui sera
Ouais, mais parce que justement moi je
t'ai dit parce que tu m'as dit est-ce
qu'il faut commencer par J'ai dit moi je
pense qu'il faut commencer par ça parce
que ça c'est simple, ça c'est des
petites choses, c'est des choses qui
font pas la révolution.
Bah ouais, enfin bon quand même c'est
pas c'est pas infléchir de façon
drastique notre qualité de vie si au
lieu de se chauffer à 22, on se chauffe
à 17 quoi. Bon 18, bon, j'en sais rien.
Donc ça je pense pour moi, c'est ce que
j'appelle les petites choses. Euh quit à
ce qu'il y a des limites un peu un peu
autoritaires. Après comme la question
était, est-ce qu'il faut démanteler les
grands groupes ? Ça, c'est les grosses
choses. Ça ça veut dire qu' ça implique
de repenser de façon très profonde notre
notre vision du monde en fait, notre
système économique et donc finalement
notre système de développement et
cetera. Oui, moi je suis complètement
persuadé qu'il y a un problème avec la
manière dont on fonctionne en ce moment.
C'estd que puisqu'on parle d'écologie,
on pense la nature comme une ressource.
En fait, c'est complètement dingue. On
la pense pas comme une essence ou une
existence en tant que telle. Elle a pas
d'existence en tant que telle. Elle
n'est là que pour nous fournir une
ressource. Alors, les grands groupes,
pour moi, c'est même pas spécifique à
eux. Ils sont simplement plus puissants
et plus méchants, on va dire, que les
autres. Donc c'est c'est une
amplification d'un phénomène mais qui
existe aussi à à plein d'autres échelles
en réalité. simplement effectivement
comme ils ont une puissance de frappe
qui sont comme une mesure et
généralement euh disons des des
principes qui sont assez voilà avec
lesquels on peut s'arranger assez
facilement, bah oui, le leur impact est
encore bien pire que les autres. Mais
mais par exemple, il y a des pays hein
qui font de l'expérimentation
intéressante en ce moment. Alors c'est
des petits pays mais tu sais qui
essayent de donner une sorte de statut
juridique, d'existence juridique à des
fleuves, à des forêts et cetera.
Starica.
À ce stade, je sais pas si c'est de la
poudre aux yeux ou si c'est vraiment une
déconstruction radicale de du monde dans
lequel on vit. J'ai aucune idée de ce
que ça va donner. Mais en tout cas, moi
je trouve ça bien qu'ils essayent même,
tu vois, il y a eu la Zade là de
Notredame des Landes il y a pas très
longtemps.
Euh moi, j'y suis pas allé. Je connais
pas les gens, j'ai aucun ami qui qui
faisait partie des adistes. Donc je ne
sais que ce que j'ai lu dans la presse.
Mais avec cette réserve-là, j'ai trouvé
intéressant que des gens essayent autre
chose. Voilà, les gens essayent autre
chose. Euh avec ce slogan qui était
marrant, qui était de dire "On ne défend
pas la nature, on a la nature." Ouais,
c'est pas mal. C'était assez péchu comme
idée. Et en fait, qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
? On leur a envoyé 2000 gendarmes, quoi.
Moi, je trouve ça quand même stupéfiant.
Je dire on fait finalement ces
expérimentateurs peut-être qu'il se
plantent, j'en sais rien, mais
expérimenter autre chose c'est vital
aujourd'hui. C'est exactement ce qu'il
faut faire. Et là on voit qu'on a eu le
clash entre quoi ? Entre le fait quee
effectivement c'était hors la loi. C'est
vrai he ils avaient pas le droit d'être
où ils étaient. Et donc il y a eu il y a
une il y a une incompatibilité entre le
droit de propriété qu'il n'avait pas et
la tentative de sauver le monde qui
était ce qui tentait de faire voix plus
large
et on a t dit bah le droit de propriété
est plus important que la tentative
parce que c'était intéressant ce qu'ils
ont fait quand même ces côtés
interdépendance ce côté quand on leur a
dit faites des fiches de candidature
individuelle ils ont dit non ça n'a de
sens que globalement parce qu'on est une
économie globale et on ne peut survivre
que parce qu'on est tous là. Moi, je me
suis dit c'est vachement fort ce qu'ils
font ces mecs. Après, j'en sais rien si
ça marche. J'y étais pas. Mais en tant
au moins qu'expérimentation, j'aurais
envie de leur dire "Mais allez-y quoi,
allez-y à fond, on va voir ce que ça
donne. On a peut-être un truc à faire
avec ça." Et on leur dit "Cassez-vous
quoi."
Ouais, parce que vous mettez peut-être
en danger quelque chose de plus grand,
du moins vous mettez en danger peut-être
des intérêts beaucoup plus puissants.
Bah oui, mais on a plus le choix.
Imagine propager ce type d'idéologie à
grande échelle, hein. Qui c'est qui va
financer les campagnes politiques ? Tu
déconnes quand même ? Merde.
Ouais, ouais. Bien sûr, bien sûr.
Alors, prochain prochain rapport du
question d'internet. Prochain rapport du
JC virgule des idées, point
d'interrogation, des fuites point
d'interrogation.
Euh
bah non, des fuites non. Moi, je fais
pas partie du GC, donc voilà, j'ai pas
j'ai pas mes entrées là-bas. Mais enfin,
de toute façon, on a l'habitude quoi.
Chaque rapport est un peu plus alarmant
que le précédent. Voilà, je vois pas
pourquoi ça changerait. Donc, on a des
gens très compétents qui nous expliquent
que ça va pas. Et euh
moi, j'ai été invité une fois par euh
par quelqu'un, j'ai pas tellement envie
de dire son nom quand même, ça m'embête
un peu, qui est un homme américain très
riche euh chef d'entreprise euh qui
organise un petit tout petit peu moins
[raclement de gorge] riche qui organise
des espèces de conférences un peu
privées pour euh voilà pour
Tu as payé pour ça ?
Non, pour phosphorer quoi. On se réunit
entre gens intelligents.
Combien de personnes ? trentaine et là
j'ai vu tout le monde était climatoque
tous les gens alors les gens qui étaient
là c'était pas des des paysans texant
c'était des doyen d'université et cetera
c'était que des gens qui avaient un très
haut niveau d'étude qui parlaient très
bien très cultur ils étaient tous
persuadés qu'il y avait pas de
réchauffement climatiqu
donne le nom de donne le nom c'est le
directeur de PayPal
de PayPal
impeccable
ils sont tous climatoceptiques parce que
tuas tuas tuas tu as pas une
parce que ça les arrange tout simplement
parce que effectivement quand tu quand
tu quand tu vis dans ce monde là si tu
te dis que ce que tu es en train de
faire tue le monde bah faut que tu
arrête et ils ont pas envie parce que
ces gens sont pas méchants. Le pire
c'est que bon certains étaient assez
cyniques, mais la plupart des gens qui
étaient présents à cette réunion c'était
des braves pères de famille et mère de
famille qui avaient envie que leurs
enfants vivent bien. En fait c'était pas
des salots hein. Je veux dire certains
ils croyaient vraiment parce que il y a
les deux hein il y a les gens qui sont
parfaitement conscients du problème mais
qui sont foutent ils veulent juste jouir
au maximum. Ça, je pense que c'est
Trump. Enfin, je suppose. Enfin, pour
Trump, il est tellement fou qu'on peut
pas savoir en fait. Mais voilà, c'est ça
clique, on va dire. Et puis il y a des
gens qui sont sincères. Alors, les
sincères, ça c'est le pire. C'est c'est
c'est le pire ça. Là, moi je il y a un
type qui m'a expliqué que en fait euh
c'était un devoir moral de PV
universitaire, chirurgien. Alors après,
j'ai compris que c'est parce qu'en fait
Dieu nous avait commandé de nous
développer maximalement, de nous
reproduire maximalement et que donc en
fait la pollution, évidemment c'était
pas le but en tant que tel, mais c'était
un corélat de l'expansionnisme humain et
que tout ce qui freinait
l'expansionnisme humain en réalité
s'opposait au commandement divin. Il
était très sympa ce type là. Et là là
c'est compliqué là, je savais pas trop
quoi faire.
Glock 19.
Bon voilà, écoute, on verra. Mais donc
voilà, il y a plein d'intérêts partout
contre lesquels il va falloir se se
battre. Euh moi je pense quand même que
la plupart des gens sont saint d'esprit.
La plupart des gens ont pas envie que
leurs gamins vivent dans un désert. Euh
donc voilà, maintenant on arrête
l'économie.
La plupart des gens la plupart des gens
sont saintes esprit mais la plupart des
gens n'ont pas le pouvoir de de la upper
classe.
Euh est-ce que les fous ont pris le
contrôle de l'asile ?
Moi je pense que je pense que non.
D'abord, je pense pas qu'il soit fou. Je
pense quand même que la plupart la
plupart des des gens qui sont aux
commande sont sont saint d'esprit.
Et je pense que c'est pas nouveau. Je je
veux dire, quand on regarde le 20e
siècle dont on sort, merde, c'était pas
exemplaire hein quand même. On a fait 60
millions de morts à la deuxième guerre
mondiale et pas beaucoup moins à la
première. C'était peut-être le pire
siècle de l'histoire. Donc c'est pas
combien milliard faut nous attendre,
c'est combien de milliards de morts ?
Ça risque d'être pire. C'est sûr que si
on se projette sur ce qui se passe pas
actuellement, ça sera probablement pire.
Donc la question d'internet qui vient de
tomber. À quelle échelle de temps se
situe le combat pour le climat ? Il nous
reste combien de temps ?
Oui, alors ça il nous reste combien de
temps ? Ça m enfin ça m'agace pas la
question hein, mais la réponse parce que
euh
moi je ferais pas je tomberai pas dans
le truc là des collègues qui sont très
bien intentionnés mais qui nous disent
il nous reste 2 ans. Le problème c'est
qu'il disent déjà ça il y a 10 ans et
donc si dans 2 ans il s'est rien passé
le mec il ferme il fait quoi ? Il ferme
sa gueule il dit bah pardon c'est trop
tard. Non ça veut rien dire en fait. Je
pense que c'est mal posé. Si on se
demande euh il nous reste combien de
temps pour que il n'y ait aucun dégât,
ah bah c'est déjà trop tard. Donc ça la
réponse elle est facile. Il aurait fallu
le faire il y a 100 ans. Donc si la
question est est-ce que c'est déjà trop
tard pour que il y ait des effets
dramatiques sur la biodiversité, sur les
espèces, sur les gens et cetera, oui, il
est déjà trop tard. Ces effets vont
avoir lieu, c'est certain. Mais après,
il y a différentes manières de dire trop
tard. On prenait l'exemple de la guerre.
La Seconde Guerre mondiale, il y a eu 60
millions de personnes. C'est un désastre
absolu. Pourtant, ça aurait pu être
pire. Il aurait pu en avoir 300
millions. Donc là, on en est là. On s on
on se dit il y a un gros problème mais
jusqu'où est-ce qu'on veut que le gros
problème devienne une tragédie sans
précédent dans l'histoire. Donc on peut
pas dire euh à partir jusqu'à quand on a
ou dire c'est trop tard. Ça veut rien
dire. Il y a il y a évidemment des
formes de vie qui vont euh perdurer
hein, même si on fait une catastrophe
nucléaire. Il y aura des araignées qui
vont s'en sortir. Donc à la fin il
restera quelque chose. Donc on peut pas
se dire tout dépend de ce qu'on attend.
Euh si on attend euh des conséquences
vivables pour l'humanité et la plupart
des espèces animales, c'est vraiment
vraiment maintenant mais c'est
maintenant en force quoi. C'est c'est
pas simplement de dire à partir de
maintenant on va croître moins vite dans
nos émissions de carbone. Non non c'est
pas ça. C'est on décroit à partir de
maintenant. Parce que si on décroit à
partir de maintenant, la température,
elle continue de monter pendant 100 à
200 ans. C'est des effets à très long
terme. Donc euh oui, c'est sûr que si on
veut limiter la casse, faut aller très
vite. Ça en prend pas du tout le chemin.
Il y a aucun pays, aucun grand pays en
tout cas qui le fait en ce moment.
Bon, si on parlait un peu de philosophie
des sciences,
c'est moins qu'on c'est moins [rires]
c'est c'est Ouais. Il y a moins d'affè,
moins anxiogène. Bah, pas tant que ça
pour moi en fait parce que parce que
curieusement, je me suis fait plus
allumer sur des sujets de philosophie
des sciences que sur d'autres. Je sais
pas pourquoi d'ailleurs euh quelque part
c'est intéressant parce que ça prouve
que le sujet laisse pas les gens
indifférents et que quand tu réfléchis
un peu à ce que dit la science, quand tu
considères ce qui est mon cas que la
science c'est une chose magnifique,
ouais je refais mon métier [toux] pardon
mais que pour autant c'est pas forcément
la vérité ultime sur le réel ce que je
crois. Euh il y a des gens que ça met en
inconfort, plus qu'en inconfort, en
fait, il y a des gens que ça énerve, que
ça agace même et euh et ça je sais pas
pourquoi. Donc euh et et et je pense que
c'est intéressant, c'est même lié à ce
qu'on dit avant d'ailleurs parce qu'on
convoque tout le temps l'argument
scientifique et en même temps il est pas
suffisant. C'estd que tu vois par
exemple, je peux faire une toute petite
digression là parce qu'on a parlé
beaucoup écologie mais il y a une
question qui est qui est connexe à
celle-là qui est celle de des animaux
mais en tant que personne, pas en tant
qu'espèce, vraiment en tant que
personne. Bon moi je suis aussi
végétarien et cetera. J'aimerais bien
que tout le monde le devienne.
D'ailleurs, là, je peux aussi être
parfaitement factuel, hein. Être
végétarien, donc l'industrie de la
viande est la plus polluante de toutes
les industries. Donc pour la planète,
c'est un très très bon geste. Pour
l'humanité, c'est un double bon geste à
l'échelle individuelle. Euh je je vois
encore des gens qui disent "Moi, je
mange de la viande pour ma santé." Je
veux dire, aujourd'hui, c'est acté,
c'est pas c'est acté, on diminue le
nombre de mortalité précoce en étant
végétarien, on le diminue encore plus en
étant végan. Les cancers du colombe, il
n'a quasiment plus chez les végan hein.
Donc quand on nous dit que la viande
c'est le truc naturel qui il y a un non
voilà donc ça c'est ça c'est prends des
compléments alimentaires ou pas ?
Je prends de la B12 c'est presque rien.
Tu fer un peu ? Non
non bah en fait je fais je fais une
analyse de sang tous les 2 ans et mon
fer est est très bon. Donc dans les
lentilles il y en a. Et et le troisième
truc, c'est qu'évidemment bah c'est très
bon pour les animaux parce que quand
même quand on voit ce qui se passe dans
un abattoir, je je connais quasiment pas
de gens qui mangent de la viande et qui
sont sereins par rapport à ça. Moi je
respecte qu'ils sont sereins à la
limite. Les gens qui regardent les
animaux en train d'agoniser parce que
quand même la moitié des animaux he sont
encore conscients au moment où ils se
vident de leur sang et cetera. Euh les
gens qui disent ouais bah ouais ch what.
OK, je veux dire ils sont cohérents avec
eux-mêmes. Mais en fait 99 % des gens
qui mangent de la viande peuvent pas
regarder ça en fait. Et donc là, il y a
quand même un problème de dissonance
cognitive qui est qui est juste
ingérable, quoi. Bon, ça euh et là ce
que je voulais dire, parce que tu
parlais de science, euh c'est que il y a
des arguments scientifiques qui sont des
arguments qui disent "Mais attention,
les animaux souffrent". Évidemment, je
veux dire, on peut le montrer par des
expériences qui sont indéniables. La
plupart des animaux ont eu conscience, à
mon avis, probablement tous, mais enfin
en tous les cas, pour les mammifères,
pour les crustacés, pour et cetera, même
pour certains insectes aujourd'hui,
c'est pratique. Les oiseaux, tout ça,
c'est pratiquement certain. Donc là, il
y a un argument scientifique qui qu'on
peut faire valoir, mais l'argument
scientifique, ce que je veux dire, c'est
qu'il est jamais suffisant parce que au
bout d'un moment, qu'est-ce que tu en
fais une fois que tu sais ? Ça, ça
relève de ta décision. Tu vois, c'est ce
que You' appelait la guillotine, quoi.
C'est-à-dire que il y a jamais un
passage nécessaire euh du scientifique à
l'éthique. Ça, ça dépend de nous et ça
dépend pas des des savants quoi ou des
chercheurs. Et donc et donc je crois que
la science, elle est essentielle mais
elle peut jamais être autonome. On peut
il y a une sorte alors je vais être
clair. J'ai un rapport intéressant et un
peu conflictuel à tout ce qui est
zétique, fact checking et cetera. Euh
vraiment pour moi c'est un problème très
compliqué en fait parce que par rapport
au menteurs genre Trump c'est très bien
ce qu'ils font. C'estàd que les mecs sa
conseillère la madame Conley ou je sais
plus quoi Conway qui porte bien son nom
qui invente une tragédie qui a jamais eu
lieu. Bon génial. Il y a des gens qui
disent fact checking vous parlez d'un
truc en fait c'est faux ça n'existe pas.
Bon très bien ça je comment être contre
je il rappelle les politiques menteurs à
la vérité. C'est super par rapport aux
gens qui disent que la terre est plate
c'est ils sont hyper patients. Moi je
j'admire leur pédagogie. des montres
machin, pourquoi la terre est pas plate
? Donc pour tout ça, c'est très bien.
Mais dès qu'on commence à parler des
choses subtiles, pas les gros menteurs,
pas les salots, pas les fous, mais les
choses subtiles, là c'est vachement
compliqué parce que cette tendance se
développe en disant on va faire du fact
checking. Ouais, mais on va checker quoi
? Parce que si on parle du nucléaire par
exemple, un sujet hyper polémique,
[grognement] on a un débat entre deux
personnes sur savoir quel est l'impact
écologique du nucléaire. Parlons même
que du CO2. Euh donc le mec de DF va
dire "Bah il est quas nul hein, une
centrale nucléaire ça rejette euh de la
vapeur d'eau, ce qui est vrai." Et l'eau
dit "Non, c'est pas vrai, c'est un
impact un impact euh et un rejet de
CO2." Et là, le journaliste va dire
"Bah, on va faire du fact checking, on
va savoir quelle est la vérité." C'est
Ouais, mais ça dépend comment tu
comptes. Est-ce que tu inclus par
exemple le coût le le la consommation de
CO2 associée à l'extraction de l'uranium
qui strict auensinsu n'est pas du tout
émis par la centrale mais ce qui
intervient quand même dans la chaîne.
Est-ce que tu inclus démantellement par
exemple qui n'est pas non plus qui ne
fait pas partie de l'exploitation mais
qu'il faudra probablement faire un jour
? Et donc
j'aime bien le facting et en même temps
je pense qu'il faut faire très attention
parce que souvent c'est une c'est une
simplification du réel. C'est on fait
comme si c'était simple alors que ça
l'est pas. J'avais me donner exprès un
exemple contre moi que bon comme tu l'as
compris, j'ai pas beaucoup de sympathie
pour Trump mais il y a eu cette
polémique tu sais le lendemain de son
investiture parce qu'il y avait eu des
photos où on voyait qu'il y avait moins
de monde qu' l'investiture d'Obama et
puis ses conseillers ont dit "Oui mais
enfin souvent je sais plus quoi, il y a
plus version versions du réel ou un truc
comme ça." Ah oui oui bon plus versions
du réel et ça soulevé un tollé. Non non
non non, il y a pas plusieurs versions,
il y en a qu'une. Mais là pour le et je
le dis comme une auto pque en fait, je
me je voilà,
j'aurais presque envie de donner raison
à Trump parce que imagine, c'était pas
le cas en vrai hein, mais imagine qu'il
est plus et qu'il a fait 15°gr de moins
qu'à la cérémonie d'investiture d'Obama.
En fait, à ce moment-là, le fait qu'il y
a eu deux fois moins de personnes ne
voulait absolument rien dire sur sa sur
sa popularité. Et donc le facturer qui
dit "mesurons le nombre de personnes."
Oui, ça on peut le faire. le nombre de
personnes qu'il y a euh c'est pas une
vue de l'esprit, on peut le compter,
mais c'est pas ça qui nous intéresse,
c'est d'interpréter ça en tant que
révélateur de la popularité. Et ça si tu
tiens pas compte de la météo de s'il y a
un match de foot en même temps ou je ne
sais quoi, ça n'a plus de valeur. Donc
j'ai envie qu'on soit un peu subtil
quoi. Les gens qui disent le
réchauffement climatique n'existe pas,
OK, ça c'est des idiots ou des salots,
on les fa check et on leur démontre par
A + B qu' disent n'importe quoi ou les
négationnistes. Enfin bon, voilà, ça
c'est facile ça. Mais dès qu'on parle de
choses un peu subtiles et par exemple de
savoir en France qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire demain ? Est-ce qu'il
faut fermer toutes les centrales
nucléaires de façon urgente ou pas ?
Pour moi, c'est subtil. Franchement, je
je ne sais pas mon âme et conscience ce
qui ce qu'il faudrait faire à court
terme en France. Je ne sais pas. Et et
donc là, je pense que bah il faut il
faut oser gérer un peu la complexité. Et
ça, en philosophie des sciences, il y a
pas beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui qui
sont prêts à l'entendre. Ils pensent
qu'en fait la science, c'est une espèce
de parole divine qui va te donner la
bonne réponse quelle que soit ta
question. Bah c'est juste pas le cas en
fait parce que le problème il y a plein
de manières différentes de le regarder
et moi je suis voilà j'aime bien qu'on
fasse pas semblant en fait qu'on mente
pas et qu'on dise bah c'est compliqué on
va rien.
Tu tu parles de subtilité de tu parles
de complexité des choses et c'est une
question qui revient souvent euh dans
notre chaîne. Est-ce que la population a
les armes cognitives pour comprendre Ne
rigole pas s'il te plaît.
Est-ce que
Non non c'est un pays de con. Non, je
plaisante. Je sais pas moi, c'est le
paris. Écoute, dans ma petite expérience
à moi, j'ai jamais été vraiment déçu.
Enfin, individuellement si, on est tout
le temps déçu par des gens. Mais
à la fac de Grenoble, quand je suis
arrivé, donc il y a 15 ans, 20 ans,
quand j'ai eu mon poste, on m'a demandé
de faire un cours de math en filière
ingénierie électrique, électrotechnique,
automatique. Bon, euh c'est des gens qui
sont franchement pas très voler, c'est
ça ?
Non, non. Bah c'est des gens qui sont
pas très bons scolairement si tu veux
parce que les gens qui sont bons en mat
ils vont en prépa ou alors ils vont
machin ou alors ils vont dans les et
cetera. Donc les gens qui vont se
retrouver dans une licence d'une fac
comme ça pour faire de
l'électrotechnique ils avaient pas
mention au bac hein. Et en plus ils
aiment pas les maths. Sinon ils seront
en licence de math ou de physique. S'ils
font de l'électricité c'est parce qu'ils
aiment maniper tu vois. Donc je me
retrouvais à faire un cours de math à
des gens qui un était pas bon en math et
deux étaient pas bon en général suivant
les critères universitaires. Donc le
chef de filière me dit "Bon, c'est pas
des cadors, hein, tu leur apprends euh
les trucs de base, inverser des
matrices, machin ce qui va leur servir
dans leur boulot. Moi, je sais même plus
comment on inverse une matrice,
j'utilise des logiciels pour ça." Donc
j'ai fait exactement le contraire. Je
leur ai dit, "On va faire qu'est-ce
qu'un nombre ?" et on a passé 25 he à
faire construction du corps des réel,
des machins hyper théoriques. Et en
fait, je le dis sans prétention parce
que parfois je me plante mais là à la
fin, j'étais le prof préféré. C'est la
matière qu'ils ont préféré. Le rest m'a
dit "Mais pour commencer les maths leur
matière préférée quoi." Bah je crois
qu'en fait quand on prend pas les gens
pour des cons
mais il faut un peu de temps
il faut accepter de bousculer les murs.
Ouais.
Ce qu'on essaie de faire. Non mais c'est
pour ça que la bonat est géniale parce
que c'est vrai que si on a 30 secondes,
on peut pas. On est obligé de prendre
les gens pour des cons. C'est du slogan,
on n pas le choix. Et c'est vrai que ça
bon oui, il y a encore quelques médias
où c'est possible mais c'est devenu
super rare.
C'est pour ça qu'on essaie aussi d'être
l'avocat du diable, de titiller les gens
en en prenant un rôle en
Ah mais moi je suis le diable donc c'est
bon. Moi je suis casse-couill moi.
[rires]
Alors question d'internet. Quelle place
pour l'art, les artistes, la création
dans ce combat, dans ce monde et dans
celui qui vient ? Bah
immense. Moi, je moi je
[soupir]
Non mais pour moi la question de l'art,
elle elle est complètement démesurée en
fait parce que et d'ailleurs ça aussi en
terme d'enseignement, j'en reviens pas
quoi. Comment on en est arrivé à un
monde où finalement si tu veux que tes
gamins réussissent, faut qu'il soient
bon en math quoi quand même pour le dire
en une phrase, la vérité en ce moment de
l'école française c'est ça. Alors que
l'art est un espace de créativité.
d'expression qui est extraordinaire et
qui est complètement dévalorisé. Donc
notre mépris finalement de la de
l'appétence et de la créativité
artistique, moi me fait horreur. J'aime
bien les maths aussi hein, comme tu l'as
compris, mais pas au détriment du reste
quoi. Et et l'art c'est vraiment je
trouve le levier qui permet pas
forcément de changer le monde
directement mais de de te montrer les
prismes sur le monde auxquels tu avais
pas accès. Par exemple,
bon là, j'ai été conseillé pour un film
de science-fiction et ça me fait chier
d'avance parce qu'on va me dire que les
scèes avec les trous noirs et cetera
sont pas réalistes. Moi je trouve que le
film est très bien. Mais on s'en f High
de Claire Deis qui vient d'être présenté
au festival de Toronto qui fait
scandale. Moi j'adore. Il y a des gens
qui sont partis avant la fin et cetera.
Bon, il y a des gens qui disent que
c'est nouveau Tarkovski, que c'est
formidable et tout. Bon, très bien, ça
divise, parfait. Du coup, c'est pas fad.
Mais moi en tant que scientifique, on
m'attend au tournant et je le sais, on
va me dire "Ouais mais là votre trou
noir, il ressemble pas du tout à ce que
ce serait un vrai trou noir" mais ça me
casse les couilles. J'en ai rien à
[__] que ça ressemble pas à un vrai
trou noir. C'est pas le problème. Et et
alors et Picasso, vous croyez vraiment
qu'avec les deux yeux du même côté, ça
ressemble à une bonne femme ? Bien sûr
que non. Ça autre chose. Ça autre chose
et bien sûr qu'il faut rendre sensible
et et l'art est exactement là pour ça.
Et en fait, on en a tous besoin, même
les plus intelligents d'entre nous. Euh
je suis désolé, c'est pas pareil quoi.
Euh tu peux savoir que les réfugiés
morts devant nos frontières closentes,
quand tu vois un gamin qui est qui est à
2 m devant toi et et qui est mort, c'est
pas pareil. On on est comme ça. Et et
là, c'est aussi ce levier, pas seulement
en terme militant hein, mais vraiment en
terme de déconstruction des évidences
qui d'un seul coup rend sensible, donc
rends les autres rapports au monde. Donc
moi, je pense que le rôle il est il est
très important. Voilà.
Bon, si on parlait un peu des trous
noirs, on va te on va te laisser le
micro pour nous parler de science.
Ouais. Tu veux nous parler de quoi ?
Euh ouais, trou noir si tu veux. On peut
parler du big bang, on peut parler de
relativité, du temps, de l'espace.
Qu'est-ce qui te plaît ?
Allez, on se fait la totale.
La totale. Bon, alors on va faire vite
et bien. Non
non, non. On fait vite, long et bien.
On fait long et long et mal. Ouais,
d'accord. Non, bon, sérieusement, euh
bah voilà, moi je travaille sur la
relativité générale. C'est une théorie
que j'adore qui a été inventée par
Einstein. Plus elle s'appelle
relativité. Ça m'amuse juste pour
emmerder le monde parce que comme on me
reproche parfois d'être relativiste au
sens cognitif, ça m'amuse. Ah, je fais
une parenthèse là-dessus parce que
relativisme, ça c'est le le reproche que
que les gens qui m'aiment pas me font
tout le temps. J'aurais juste clarifier
là-dessus parce que il y a plein de
façons de le comprendre. Tu vois, il y a
le relativisme niiliste qui consiste à
dire tout se vaut, tout se vaut. Bah
oui, le nazisme, machin, tout ça, ça se
vaut. Non, mais personne ne dit ça.
C'est le contraire de ce que je pense.
Évidemment, c'est pour ça que je suis
engagé. Je suis venu aujourd'hui de voir
parce que j'ai envie de faire passer un
message. Donc ce relativisme là qui dit
rien n'est plus vrai qu'autre chose,
rien n'est plus juste, rien n'est
meilleur. C'est juste débile. Aucun
philosophe dans l'histoire n'a dit ça.
D'ailleurs, je sais même pas à qui on
réfère. cette ce courant n'est porté par
personne. Mais il y a l'autre
relativisme qui est celui que je défends
qui est pas du tout ça, qui est le
contraire de ça, qui est dire oui oui
bien sûr faut s'engager, faut se battre
et cetera, mais faut aussi faire
attention que les modes d'évaluation des
connaissances, bah ils sont pas God
given quoi. C'est pas Dieu qui les
donne, c'est aussi nous qui les
choisissons. Et donc faut faire gaffe
parce que parfois il y a des choses qui
nous paraissent parfaitement justes,
juste aussi bien au sens éthique qu'au
sens scientifique. Mais en fait, quand
tu vas décadrer un peu les modes
d'évaluation, tu vas te rendre compte
qu'en réalité, ils sont parfaitement
injustes. Donc ce que j'appelle
relativisme, c'est le fait de d'intégrer
même les structures d'évaluation et les
cadres de pensée dans le contexte histor
historique et culturel qui les génère et
de surtout pas faire l'erreur qui
consiste à croire que bah ça bien sûr
c'est pour l'éternité parce que c'est
juste faux en fait. Tout ça a aussi
évolué. Donc pour moi c'est une sorte tu
vois de de niveau comme ça de en fait de
précision et d'humilité supplémentaire
voilà et pas de laxisme en fait à
l'inverse. Bon mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec la relativité d'Instein à part le
nom. Donc la relativité d'Instein, ben
c'est un truc magnifique parce que en
physique d'habitude, il y a deux choses.
Il y a les objets, donc les bonhommes et
les bonnes femmes. Et puis il y a le
cadre, c'est-à-dire l'espace et le
temps. Donc l'espace et le temps, c'est
ce dans quoi on est et puis nous on est
les choses qui sont dedans. Et les et
les deux se parlent pas parce que pour
Newton ou C tous ces gens-là, l'espace
et le temps c'est complètement immuable.
Donc c'est là pour toujours, depuis
toujours et on peut rien y faire. Alors
que les objets, bah c'est sur quoi on
agit quoi. Là je peux taper sur le
fauteuil et cetera. Et en fait ce qui a
compris Einstein c'est que c'était pas
vrai. C'estàd que l'espace et le temps
c'était des objets comme le reste. Et ça
c'est quand même une révolution
extraordinaire parce que du coup si
c'est des objets comme le reste, ça veut
dire qu'ils sont en évolution, ça veut
dire qu'on peut interagir avec eux, ça
veut dire qu'on peut les mesurer. Et
finalement toute la cosmologie,
c'est-à-dire la science de l'univers,
elle est fondée là-dessus. Et ce qu'on a
compris en fait, c'est que
vraisemblablement ce modèle du Big Bang
qui est aujourd'hui assez populaire, en
fait ce qu'il relate ou plus exactement
ce dont il résulte, c'est de l'expansion
de l'espace. Et donc quand on dit que
les galaxies s'éloignent, c'est à moitié
vrai parce que c'est pas parce qu'elles
bougent en fait, c'est parce qu'elles
sont prisonnières de l'espace et
l'espace lui-même est en train d'enfler
un peu comme si on était dans un
gigantesque Schwimgum qui était en train
de gonfler. Et donc en fait, on est en
train d'observer le mouvement propre de
l'espace. Et ça, ça a lieu en cosmologie
et puis ça a lieu aussi dans les trous
noirs qui sont en train d'imploser et
cetera. Et ça, je trouve que c'est très
beau aussi en terme philosophique parce
que c'est une sorte de perte
d'absoluité. Tu vois, avant Einstein, on
avait quand même un truc en commun quoi.
C'était l'espace et le temps. Et là,
d'un seul coup, tout se délite et en
fait, tout devient relationnel. Il y a
plus d'ici et de là absolu. Il y a juste
des choses qui font les unes par rapport
aux autres. Et c'est quand même assez
décapant. Par exemple, à l'intérieur
d'un trou noir, on se rend compte que le
temps devient de l'espace, que l'espace
devient du temps. On se rend compte que
la surface d'un trou noir, le temps
entre guillemets est infiniment dilaté.
Donc si par exemple tu es dans le monde
extérieur, tu vas à la surface d'un trou
noir et tu retournes, il peut sêtre
passer 2 minutes pour toi mais il s'est
passé 10000 ans dans le reste de
l'univers. Et tu te demandes et en
vérité c'est 2 minutes ou c'est 10000
ans ? Bah en vérité les deux sont brus
il s'est vraiment passé 2 minutes pour
soi et c'est vraiment passé 10000 ans
ailleurs. Donc du coup c'est une chance
qui mathématiquement elle est très bien
définie he c'est pas du tout un grand
n'importe quoi. C'est hyper rigoureux
mais en même temps en terme
d'appréhension psychique ça ouvre quand
même des boîtes comme ça qui sont juste
presque impossibles en fait à cerner
pour l'esprit humain.
Tu continues ou je te je t'as stic un
peu
continue ? Bah c'est non vas-y
on a reçu euh il y a pas très longtemps
quelqu'un qui s'appelle Jean-Pierre
Petit.
Ah euh qui nous a parlé de son modèle
Janus. On a essayé d'être corrosif avec
lui. Elle secouait très fort avec un
respect que peu ont compris. On lui a on
lui a dit que les félés laissaient
passer la lumière.
Est-ce que tu as étudié son modèle Janus
?
Bon euh
alors
je n'ai pas étudié son modèle Janius en
fait je vais être absolument sincère. Il
est tout à fait possible que ce modèle
soit recevable au au au sens des
critères scientifiques académiques
actuels. Bon je sais qu'il a été plus ou
moins blacklisté de certains serveurs
archive et cetera. Bon je ne sais pas si
c'est justifié. Franchement, je ne sais
pas le peu que j'en ai vu. Ouais. Enfin,
je veux dire, c'est pas n'importe quoi.
Il sait quand même de quoi il parle. Il
il a des des des je pense des
connaissance de relativité. J'ai jamais
lu les articles. Ce que j'ai un entendu,
c'est en tous les cas pas plus délirant
que beaucoup d'articles de physique
théorique qui sont publiés aujourd'hui,
y compris par moi. Donc je pense que
c'est un modèle qui est pas idiot. Mais
ce que je crois, il n'a pas compris et
ses disciples n'ont pas compris, c'est
que des modèles comme ça, il y en a des
milliers. Et donc moi, je me suis fait
quand même limite harceler, hein, par
des fans de Jean-Pierre Petit qui qui me
tweet tous les jours, mais alors vous
avez pourquoi vous refusez le débat avec
lui ? Mais c'est pas que je refuse en
fait, c'est que j'ai autre chose à faire
quoi. C'est que il y en a des milliers
de débats des modèles comme ça. En fait,
moi j'ai une pile comme ça de de modèles
que je je meurs d'envie de découvrir et
simplement j'ai pas eu le temps encore
de les regarder. Il se trouve que par
rapport à mes priorités propres, le
modèle de Jean-Pierre Petit, c'est juste
pas du tout ma priorité. Et donc du
coup, j'ai l'impression qu'il se croit
ostracisé du genre mais mais pourquoi
vous m'invitez pas pour faire un
séminaire dans mon labo ? Mais attends
mais mais il y en a des milliers
d'autres qui sont pas invités non plus
quoi. C'est c'est simplement que par
rapport à nos priorit as-t-on le droit
de ne pas travailler sur le modèle de
Jean-Pierre Petit ? En fait c'est moi
c'est ça ma question tout simplement ça
ma question. Moi je j'ai rien contre lui
en fait hein, sauf que il a des méthodes
quand même parfois un peu limite
menaçantes que j'ai pas adoré mais c'est
pas grave, ça reste des mots. Je je vais
certainement pas me scandaliser pour ça.
J'ai même une sympathie à la limite pour
le côté fran tireur hors du système.
C'est plutôt sympa. Donc j'ai rien
contre lui et ses idées en fait. Faut
juste qu'il comprenne que il est pas
seul avoir un modèle alternatif. Presque
chaque physicien théoricien qui
travaille sur la cosmologie a aussi son
modèle alternatif. Moi je lui en veux
pas de pas avoir travaillé sur mon
modèle à moi. Gen je lui demande pas
toujours alors tu as quoi à dire sur mes
calculs ? Non, il fait les siens, je
fais les miens quoi. C'est juste ça qu'
faut accepter.
C'est quoi ton modèle ?
Enfin, mon modèle, bon reste ton modèle.
C'est moi j'ai pas inventé un modèle à
proprement parler. Moi je travaille sur
la gravité quantique à boucle. C'est
Carlo Revelli qui l'a inventé, qui est
beaucoup plus génial que moi, qui est un
physicien absolui
qui est un physicien vraiment
extraordinaire qui qui a essayé de
concilier la physique d'Einstein d'un
côté et la mécanique quantique de
l'autre. Moi ce que j'ai fait c'est
d'appliquer ce modèle avec d'autres
hein, pas tout seul, à l'univers, au
trous noirs et puis on a eu des
résultats marrants, puis on a fait des
hypothèses. Je moi, j'ai fait une
hypothèse que les trous noirs se
comporteraient d'une certaine manière
quand ils s'évaporent que personne
d'autre avait supposé jusqu'à
maintenant. Probablement, c'est faux
hein. Je veux dire, moi-même j'y crois
pas trop mais j'explore, c'est mon
métier, je suis payé pour ça. J'essaie
des trucs que personne n'a exploré. Euh
99 % vont passer aux oubliettes de
l'histoire et puis à un moment donné, on
va avoir de la chance. On va on va avoir
une bonne idée et on va faire une
découverte majeure. C'est sera
probablement pas moi, mais bon, je fais
ce que je peux c'est mon c'est mon
travail.
Alors, qu'est-ce que tu entends par un
trou noir s'évapore ?
Alors, un trou noir, la définition
normalement, c'est qu'on peut rentrer
dedans et on peut pas sortir. Ça c'est
le cœur de l'être, de l'ontologie d'un
trou noir. Et en fait, il se trouve que
ça c'est vrai pour un trou noir
classique. C'està-dire le trou noir
d'Einstein ou de Newton d'ailleurs parce
que ça existait bien avant Einstein.
L'idée de trou noir, on la doit au 18e
siècle à Pierre Simon de la place et
John Mitchell. Donc on peut rentrer
dedans, on peut pas revenir vers
l'extérieur. Ça c'est la définition.
Donc a priori ça devrait pas s'évaporer
parce que si ça s'évapore, c'est que ça
ressort. Mais le problème c'est que dès
qu'on rajoute la physique quantique qui
est l'autre grande découverte du 20e
siècle et ben à ce moment-là rien ne va
plus et tout ce qu'on croyait vrai
devient faux. Et ça, on le doit en
particulier à Stephen Hawking qui a
montré que les petits trous noirs, les
pour les gros, il se passe rien, mais
devraient émettre des particules. Et en
fait, c'est un c'est un un phénomène qui
est super intéressant parce que la
manière dont ils émettent des particules
est en fait révélateur de tout ce qu'on
comprend pas en physique, c'est-à-dire
essentiellement comment concil la
physique quantique et la relativité.
Donc l'étude de ces trou noirs en
évaporation, en réel, on sait pas le
faire parce que hélas on sait pas créer
un trou noir au laboratoire. Mais ça, je
trouve ça super joli parce que ça fait
partie de ce qu'on appelle les
expériences de pensée. C'est-à-dire que
euh tu vois un peu dans dans le sillage
d'Einstein, attention hein, je me prends
pas pour Einstein, mais je veux dire à à
un un niveau très inférieur, infiniment
inférieur, c'est de perpétrer cette
tradition qui consiste à dire on n pas
forcément besoin de construire un
accélérateur à 10 milliards d'euros pour
comprendre des choses. On en a besoin
quand même. Attention, je pense que la
physique expérimentale, c'est vital
hein, mais on peut aussi en parallèle
comprendre des choses en disant "Et que
se passerait-il si ?" ce qu'on appelle
l'expérience de pensée. Tu sais,
Einstein s'imaginait chevauchant un
rayon de lumière. C'est super beau hein
et c'est comme ça qu'il a trouvé la
relativité restreinte. Donc aujourd'hui,
on imagine comme ça. On imagine un trou
noir qu'urait tel truc, on mettra un
détecteur là, qu'est-ce qui se passerait
? Et en fait, on arrive à avoir des
incohérences dans les modèles et donc à
trouver de la physique nouvelle même
sans avoir à le faire pour de vrai.
Alors, les les méga trous noir qui sont
au centre de notre Voie lacté ou au
centre de de certaines galaxies dû d du
à l'effondrement gazeux,
[soupir]
comment les scientifiques travaillent
dessus, quels sont les les ressources
finalement c'est ça qui va nous avoir.
C'est pas le réchauffement climatique.
Non, je plaise.
Je blague hein. Les trou noirs sont
évidemment pas dangereux du tout. Donc
ouais, en effet, on a un trou noir.
Tu es sûr ? Tu es sûr de ton coup avec
les trou noirs pas dangereux ? Avec la
production, le jet le jet euh l'éjection
euh de du trou noir, est-ce que ça peut
être dangereux pour la vie ?
Ah bah s'il y a un trou noir là d'un
seul coup qui passait qui venait frôer
la terre, ouais, on aurait un gros
problème, c'est sûr. Mais étant donné
qu'il y en a extrêmement peu par rapport
au Il y en a beaucoup hein dans la
galaxie chez nous là, la Voie lactée, il
y a environ 100 millions de trous noirs,
probablement un peu plus à mon avis.
Donc c'est des grands nombres mais des
étoiles, il y en a 100 milliards. Donc
tu vois par rapport au cas, il y en a
très peu. Et donc on a jamais vu une
étoile qui collisionnait la terre. Donc
tu as encore beaucoup moins de trou
noirs que d'étoiles et qu'en plus ils
sont beaucoup plus petits. Bon c'est des
probabilités quasi nules. Mais oui au
centre de la Voie lactique il y en a un
super gros qui a à peu près la m de 4
millions de fois la mage du soleil. On
l'appelle Sagitarius Astar en fait toute
la galaxie en train de tourner autour de
lui. Alors c'est vrai que c'est un peu
la mauvaise publicité parce qu'on dit
parfois que ce sont des ogres qui
dévorent tout et c'est pas vrai du tout
hein. En fait les étoiles elles tournent
comme ça de façon stable autour du trou
noir. Ça joue même plutôt le rôle de
structuration pour les pour les
galaxies. Donc c'est des choses dont on
a plutôt besoin et on est en train de
commencer à avoir les premières images
là. Donc dans quelques années, on va
avoir une sorte de photographie du trou
noir et ça c'est quand même quelque
chose de merveilleusement beau en fait.
Et il y a très peu de temps avec les
ondes gravitationnelles, pour la
première fois, on a observé deux trous
noirs qui se tournaient l'un autour de
l'autre et qui ont coalessé, c'estàd qui
ont fusionné. Et ça c'est hyper
intéressant scientifiquement mais c'est
aussi très beau philosophiquement ou al
philosophiquement c'est peut-être un peu
un peu fort mais disons
psychologiquement parce que c'est comme
si on avait un nouveau sens quoi. Tu
vois on a la vule touché le oui l'odorat
et cetera et là c'est comme si pour la
première fois dans l'histoire on pouvait
voir directement la géométrie. Alors ça
veut rien dire quoi dans la vie de tous
les jours. Voir la géométrie ça veut
rien dire. Bah oui ça veut rien dire
parce que normalement on sait pas le
faire. Mais on a inventé un détecteur
qui est capable de voir directement les
petites vibrations de l'espace en tant
que tel.
Je sais que je suis pas clair mais je
peux pas être clair parce que comme
expliquer à un aveugle de naissance que
c'est que voir bah c'est presque
impossible en fait gravitationnel. C'est
ça.
C'est ça. Ouais. Donc il y en a deux aux
États-Unis et un en Europe. Et on
commence et c'est c'est très beau parce
que c'est un geste de bah là encore de
désenthropocentrisation quoi. C'estd
queon a toujours pensé l'univers comme
étant un peu à notre image finalement
centré sur la terre puis sur le soleil
puis sur la galaxie puis sur le cosmos
et cetera. Et quand on utilise de
nouveaux médiateurs, c'est de nouveaux
euh messagers du de l'univers, bah en
fait, on se rend compte comme toujours
que le monde est pas du tout ce qu'on
attendait, euh que la diversité est bien
plus grande que ce qu'on supposait, que
l'étrangeté est bien plus grande que ce
qu'on supposait, que donc à forceori
notre position est bien plus petite et
dérisoire que ce qu'on supposait. Et et
d'ailleurs ça ça amène aussi enfin
l'humidité parfaite.
Ouais. Ouais. Et puis alors pas les zes
gravitacielles en tant que tel, mais
tout ça m'a amené aussi à réfléchir un
peu sur ce qu'on appelle le multivers.
Donc ça c'est la possibilité d'univers
multiple. Ça aussi ça a pas mal agacer
certains scientistes dur. Pourtant je je
suis toujours très prudent là-dessus.
Mais alors d'abord je vais peut-être
dire ce que c'est et dire pourquoi c'est
dangereux. Alors ce que c'est c'est quoi
? Bah c'est simplement l'idée qu'il y a
peut-être pas un seul univers. Voilà qui
a peut-être un ensemble d'univers voir
une myiade d'univers. Alors en fait
c'est pas une idée récente. On la trouve
chez Anaximandre
dans la Grèce antique. On la retrouve
ensuite à l'âge classique avec l'imnit.
on la retrouve en philosophie
contemporaine et cetera. Donc ça ça
traverse toute l'histoire en fait de la
pensée. Mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'en physique aujourd'hui, elle
intervient non pas comme une hypothèse,
tu vois, d'un mec un peu chevelu comme
moi qui se dit tiens ça serait cool qu'
est bien plein d'univers, ça serait pas
super crédible mais elle intervient
comme une conséquence mathématique de
certains de nos modèles. Donc il y a un
certain crédit qui [raclement de gorge]
est associé à ça. Alors les deux
questions intéressantes, c'est est-ce
que c'est vrai et qu'est-ce que ça
change ? Alors peut-être la plus facile,
c'est qu'est-ce que ça change ? Bah ça
change quand même pas mal de choses
parce que vivre dans non plus dans un
monde mais dans une multitude de mondes,
c'est une sacrée blessure narcissique
supplémentaire. C'est que notre univers
lui-même se retrouve déchu de son
piédestal. Donc rien qu'en terme de
récit, tu vois, ça change beaucoup de
choses. Mais en plus en terme pratique,
ça a des effets complètement directs.
Par exemple, on se demande souvent en
physique pourquoi les lois semblent si
merveilleusement adapté à l'existence de
la complexité et de la vie. Mais la vie,
c'est qu' une forme de complexité.
Alors, il y a des solutions
théologiques, hein. Dire "Bah, c'est
parce que Dieu l'a voulu. C'est possible
mais c'est pas une solution
scientifique. Il y a des solutions dire
bah on a eu de la chance, c'est possible
mais il falloir une sacrée chance hein
quand même. Et puis il y a le multivers.
Le multivers dit bah non en fait il y a
plein d'univers qui ont des lois
différentes. Donc c'est pas étonnant que
de temps en temps certaines lois soient
compatibles avec nous. C'est un peu
comme quand tu joues au l'uto quoi. Si
tu joues une fois tu es sûr de perdre,
tu es presque sûr de perdre. Mais si tu
joues une infinité de fois bah forcément
il y a des moments où tu gagnes. Des
gagnants jouer. C'est ça.
Voilà. Euh ça c'est la question facile,
c'est qu'est-ce que ça change ? Ça
change tout. Mais le versant plus
compliqué, c'est est-ce que c'est vrai ?
Ce qui est sous-entendu par là, c'est
est-ce que c'est encore de la science ?
Et ça, ça nous emmène assez loin en fait
parce que la première question c'est
est-ce que c'est de la science au sens
orthodoxe du terme ? Là, je vais être un
peu provocateur mais il y a pas de sens
orthodoxe du terme. Heureusement qu'on
fait plus de la science aujourd'hui
comme Aristote qui est peut-être un des
plus grands logiciens de l'histoire,
hein. Faut pas oublier qu'Aistote a
écrit plus de botanique que de
philosophie. Donc bien sûr que les
règles du jeu scientifique ont changé.
Donc vouloir enfermer la science dans
des règles figées serait exactement
contraire à la pratique scientifique qui
consiste à trouver les règles du jeu
pendant qu'on joue. Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? Donc çaà je pense c'est une
mauvaise question. Et ensuite même si on
prend des règles un peu conservatrices
oui je pense que le multiverse ça reste
scientifique parce que on peut quand
même de façon indirecte le mettre à
l'épreuve. Mais c'est des questions qui
sont pas neutres curieusement. Donc
c'estàd que tu vois dès qu'on commence à
réfléchir à des choses comme ça, il y a
toujours la suspicion.
Est-ce que c'est encore bien sérieux ?
Est-ce que c'est de la science orthodoxe
? Est-ce qu'on est dans l'idée géniale
ou dans l'imposture ? Mais soyons
modeste, on nen sait rien.
On nen sait rien. On verra plus tard.
Je rebondis sur ça avec une question
d'internet. Connaît-il Nassim Haramine
et sa théorie des champs unifiés ?
Ouais. Non mais là non quoi. Le peu que
j'en connais c'est bullshit total quoi.
Là je veux dire je je je pas été assisté
à ces séminaire mais le peu que j'ai vu
sur internet alors là pour moi c'est
vraiment vraiment intérêt zéro quoi.
Alors je dis intérêt zéro je vais juste
développer un peu. Alors comme en même
temps je le connais pas très bien, je
veux pas l'enfoncer par courtoisie mais
je vais dire pourquoi. Parce que vous
avez bien compris que je ne suis pas un
adepte du tout scientifique. C'està-dire
que moi je pense que les modes de pensée
même je suis pas croyant mais même la
pensée religieuse je respecte énormément
ça. La pensée artistique évidemment
poétique évidemment même mythologique je
trouve ça magnifique moi les mythes même
les gens que un peu mystiqu le magique
le miraculeux tout ça je tolère très
bien. Mais ce qui m'agace c'est les
mélanges artificiels. On fait passer
pour scientifique ce qui ne l'est pas du
tout. En fait moi ma compréhension c'est
que ce mec-là il dit n'importe quoi et
il le fait passer pour de la science. Ça
ça me plaît pas.
Bam.
Non non mais le but c'est pas d'être
méchant. Je dis ce que je pense de toute
façon. Je crois qu'il vit très bien. Je
pense qu'il est beaucoup plus riche que
moi. Il a plein de followers et
d'adeptes. Je lui veux pas de mal. Il a
même pas l'air méchant ce gars là. Je
lui veux pas de mal mais
intellectuellement pour moi c'est nul.
Bon
tu nous conseilles pas de le recevoir.
Bah ça dépend comment tu l'interview
avec une batte.
Non on n'est pas violent nous.
Euh autre question. Alors ça par contre,
je vais peut-être pas pouvoir vous aider
les gars. Est-ce qu'il a entendu parler
de l'anakea
ou paradis incommensurable ?
Non, paradis incommensurable. Ouais,
voilà, on a fond les gars.
Ouais. Bon, incommensurable, c'est un
mot ça aussi. Alors, je connais pas du
tout ça he mais c'est qui qu'on me
rapproche aussi beaucoup ça parce que il
y a toujours l'idée du réductionnisme
scientifique et quand on dit que c'est
incommensurable, je sais pas du tout
pour ce cas-là mais d'une façon générale
c'est un concept par exemple qu'on doit
en linguistique à sûre. Moi j'aime bien
cette idée d'incommensurabilité en
particulier des paradigmes
scientifiques. C'est ce que disait K ou
Fire à band. C'est c'est l'idée que en
fait c'est pas forcément facile de
comparer des visions du monde qui sont
complètement différentes et on les dit
incommensurables. Pour moi, c'est très
important ça. C'est que la question de
savoir est-ce que la cosmologie
d'Einstein est meilleure que la
cosmogonie des Égyptiens ? Moi, je
répondrai pas à ça. Elle est meilleure
pour faire des calculs. Évidemment oui.
Pour envoyer des fusées dans l'espace.
Enfin, quoi qu'on a pas besoin d'Instein
pour ça, mais évidemment oui. Euh, pour
répondre à des questions quantitatives,
évidemment oui. Mais en terme vraiment
ontologique, pour ce qui est d'une
espèce de compréhension très profonde
des choses, moi je répondrai pas à ça.
Je pense que c'est un compte mensurable
et je respecterai autant les deux.
Alors, il y a eu un petit complément
entre-temps, la Nikea, la Niakea et le
Superama de Galaxie englobant le
Superama de la Vierge dont fait partie
la Voie lactée et dont par la suite le
système solaire et en particulier.
Ah, donc c'est pas un mec en fait. Donc
là, je suis l'astrophysicien qui savait
même pas que c'était le nom d'un am. Là,
j'ai l'air con mais tant pis.
Et j'ai toujours pas compris la question
en fait plus.
Bon bah, merci en tout cas de m'avoir
appris appris ce mot que je ne
connaissais pas.
Voilà, on remercie. D'autres trucs à
aborder comme ça qui te passent par la
tête ?
Ah bah, il y en a une infinité. Ouais,
forcément. Alors sur l'affinité, choisis
en une,
bah disons que on peut parler un peu de
l'avenir. Voilà, on a parlé de la
science qui qui est comprise et je pense
que la recherche ce qui est intéressant
c'est l'inconnu. Donc l'inconnu, c'est
vers vers quoi on va, vers où on va. Et
je crois qu'en ce moment, il y a quand
même une petite crise euh en physique
des particules élémentaires,
c'est-à-dire la compréhension de
l'infiniment petit, ça repose sur la
mécanique quantique. Mécanique
quantique, ça marche très bien. C'est
super bizarre. En mécanique quantique,
il y a de l'aléatoire, il y a de
l'imprévisible, il y a du discontinu,
mais enfin ça fonctionne. Grâce à ça, on
décrit très bien ce qui se passe. On a
un modèle standard qui est remarquable
et puis auprès du grand coisionneur de
Adron du Cerne, le lâché, on a découvert
le boson de X qu'on avait prévu. Tout va
bien. Sauf que ce modèle, il est pas
complètement consistant.
On sait qu'il faut aller au-delà. On
sait vraisemblablement grâce à la
cosmologie qu' a des nouvelles
particules et on les trouve pas. Et on
avait une idée pour aller au-delà. On
appelait ça la super symétrie, peu
importe le détail, mais en gros tout le
monde y croyait dans le domaine des
physiciens, théoriciens, des particules.
Et le fait est qu'à ce jour, on ne la
voit pas. Donc finalement, c'est quand
même un peu la crise. Au niveau
expérimental, le LHC, c'est un super
succès, ça marche bien. Euh on a quand
même appris des choses, he on a vu le
boson 2 X, c'est pas un détail mais en
même temps, ce qu'on espérait aussi
voir, c'est-à-dire de la nouvelle
physique, c'est-à-dire un truc imprévu
ou alors très au-delà de ce qu'on
connaissait, là ça a raté. C'est de la
faute de personne, hein. Les ingénieurs
ont bien travaillé, on a fait ce qu'il
fallait, mais la nature nous dit "Bah
écoutez, vous pensiez que ça allait
fonctionner parce que votre théorie
était belle, elle était cohérente, elle
était consistante, elle était
prédictive, donc vous n'en doutiez même
pas. Bah ouais, mais c'est faux." Donc
tant mieux au sens où vous êtes une
surprise, mais après la surprise
négative qui est de dire en fait il n'y
a pas ce que vous pensiez, ça serait
bien qu'on a une surprise positive.
C'est oui, mais à la place, il y a ça.
Et pour le moment, le à la place, il y a
ça, on l'a pas. Et j'imagine mal comment
on va s'en sortir parce que si on veut
aller au-delà, faut une machine beaucoup
plus grosse que le LHC. Donc
typiquement, je sais pas moi, entre 50
et 100 milliards d'euros. Euh, est-ce
qu'on va la faire ? Alors, est-ce qu'on
a envie de la faire ? C'est une question
politique. Euh c'est beaucoup quand
même. Ça commence à plus être
négligeable. [grognement] Ça va être un
investissement considérable. Alors,
c'est toujours pareil hein, si on
compare ça avec les les les profits des
super multinationales, j'ai envie de
dire bah oui, évidemment, on le fait,
c'est rien par rapport à ça et c'est
tellement plus intéressant. Mais si à la
place de ça, on se dit combien de gamins
africains on pourrait sauver, là
évidemment je me sens mal. J'ai envie de
dire bah non, faudrait mieux sauver la
fin dans le monde. Bon, de toute façon,
on demandera pas mon avis, donc c'est
pas grave. Mais je veux dire, on va vers
la very big science et il y a un peu une
crise en fait. Comment progresser tout
en restant quand même à une échelle qui
n'est pas démesurée. Et puis en théorie,
on a aussi une crise, c'est qu'on a deux
grandes théories, la physique quantique,
la relativité générale et on narrive pas
à les concilier. Alors, en un certain
sens qu'on ait pas une théorie
complètement unifiée, moi ça me choque
pas. Je pense qu'il y a une certaine
diversité dans le réel. J'aimerais bien
qu'on la réhabilite autant au niveau
scientifique, politique, esthétique et
cetera. Donc peut-être qu'il y a
plusieurs théories. Le problème, c'est
que quand elles sont contradictoires, là
il y a quand même un problème de
cohérence. Et ça fait presque 100 ans
que les gens cherchent la gravité
quantique et on n'y arrive pas. On a
inventé la théorie des cordes. Enfin, je
dis on moi j'y suis pour rien. C'est
super beau. Il y a un des paires de la
théorie des cordes avec la médaille
fields don l'équivalent du prénobel de
mathématiques. Donc ces gens sont
brillants, il y a pas de doute
là-dessus. Euh mais enfin jusqu'à
maintenant, ça ne colle pas du tout avec
le réel. Euh et puis il y a 25 ans,
Carlo Revelli a inventé la physique
quantique à boucle. Moi, j'adore ça, je
travaille dessus mais faut quand même
reconnaître queon n'a pas non plus comme
en théorie des cordes, nous n'avons pas
été capable de faire une prédiction
claire qui a été vérifiée par
l'expérience. Donc il y a un peu une
crise, mais les crises, c'est bien parce
que c'est souvent à ce moment-là où il y
a des grandes ruptures, des
déconstructions, des changements de
paradigme. Bon, j'espère que ça va
arriver.
On a plein de questions sur Big Crunch
et Big Boons.
Ouais.
un mot de
Ah oui, bien sûr. Alors ça c'est c'est
vraiment mon domaine de recherche. Donc
donc avec plaisir. Alors d'abord Big
Crunch l'idée que actuellement l'univers
est en expansion comme ça et l'idée
c'est que peut-être il va se
recontracter et il va venir imploser en
un point et on appelle ça le big crunch.
Alors ça c'est possible c'est que la
théorie d'Einstein autorise ce
comportement mais elle autorise aussi le
fait que ce soit en expansion sans
jamais s'arrêter. Si tu veux les deux
sont possibles, ça dépend simplement du
contenu en matière. C'est comme si là
jette un stylo, il peut tomber à 1 m ou
il peut tomber à 5 m. Bah ça dépend
comment je le lance quoi. Et donc
actuellement avec tout ce qu'on sait,
les observations et cetera, il y a une
réponse qui semble être non ambigue,
c'est qu'il y aura pas de big crunch.
Big bones avec une déperdition
calorifique.
Une seconde, c'estd que probablement
l'univers va pas se recontracter, il va
continuer comme ça de s'épendre
indéfiniment. Bon, je peux pas le jurer
hein de toute façon quoi que je dise, tu
pourras pas me contredire mais
actuellement si j'extrapole à partir de
ce qu'on a, c'est ça la réponse claire.
Mais en revanche, il y a une autre
question qui est connexe à celle-ci et
qui connecte à ce que tu dis. C'est dire
"Oui, mais maintenant si je remonte dans
le passé, donc je vais pas dans le futur
mais je vais dans le passé." Donc dans
le passé là, il y a normalement ce qu'on
appelle le big bang. Donc c'est une
singularité et paf, l'univers apparaît.
Bah on sait pas trop comment, on sait
pas trop pourquoi et on sait pas trop à
partir d'où. Et c'est ça en effet qui
dans les modèles de gravité quantique
comme ceux sur lesquels je travaille dis
"Non, non, non, en fait, il y a pas eu
de big bang. Probablement il y a eu un
big bounce, c'est-à-dire un grand
rebond. Et donc un grand rebond, ça veut
dire qu'il y aurait eu dans le passé une
phase de contraction de l'univers. Quand
il devient extrêmement petit, il est
super dense, il rebondit. Alors, il
rebondit sur lui-même, hein, parce qu'il
y a rien à l'extraire. Il se rebondit
dessus comme une balle comme ça qui est,
il se rebondit dessus et après il repart
en expansion et actuellement on est ici
dans la phase d'expansion. Donc l'enjeu
maintenant, c'est de dire bon bah on a
des calculs, on a des modèles, on publie
mais est-ce que c'est vrai ? Bah la
réponse à ça c'est qu'il faudrait qu'on
trouve des indices observationnels de
cette éventuelle phase d'avant le rebond
parce que forcément il reste un peu des
cendres. Enfin, je dis cendre
métaphoriquement, quoi.
Des ondes gravitationnelles,
par exemple. Des ondes
gravitationnelles. Exactement. Ouais.
Exactement. Mais alors, c'est des effets
minuscules, donc c'est super dur à
trouver. Mais la bonne nouvelle, c'est
que quand même, bon, moi quand j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à ça il y a 10
ans, c'était presque de la métaphysique,
hein. C'est pas grâce à moi que ça a
changé hein, mais grâce à un certain un
ensemble de gens. Aujourd'hui, on
commence quand même à avoir des
prédictions claires dont on peut espérer
que dans quelques décennies, ça rentrera
dans le champ expérimental. Donc, je
suis assez content quand même. Ça
progresse assez vite.
D'autres choses abordé
pour ma défense ? Non, non, de toute
façon, je suis je suis fini.
Euh, un avis sur la recherche française,
le modèle universitaire.
Alors euh bon, c'est quelque part si je
compare à à l'ensemble des des des gens
qui habitent ce pays, je vais pas me
plaindre quoi. Enfin, comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure, je suis plutôt bien payé
pour faire un métier que j'adore. Je
passe mon temps à me poser des questions
que j'aurais envie de me poser, même si
on va être payé pour le faire. Je vais
pas me plaindre, je suis libre. J'ai je
choisis ce sur quoi je travaille.
Pendant mes cours, je choisis
essentiellement ce que j'aborde. Ça se
passe super bien, je crois. Enfin,
j'espère. Sinon, il y aura des comes sur
la la vidéo. Mais je crois que
globalement avec les étudiants, ils
m'aiment bien et je les aime bien. Donc
bon, oui, je suis un homme heureux,
quoi. Si c'est ça la question, c'est ça
la réponse. Mais après, il y a quand
même plein de problèmes. Euh les
problèmes, c'est quoi d'abord ? C'est
qu'on a très peu de postes. Dans ma
discipline, en physique théorique, on
avait cinq postes par an. Je crois que
ça va passer à quatre parce que la bonne
nouvelle c'est que personne n'avait osé
le faire dans les 10 dernières années
mais le nombre de postes vient enfin de
diminuer. Donc on va passer à quatre
postes par an probablement pour à peu
près 250 candidats. Faut bien voir que
les 250 candidats, je parle de gens qui
ont tous un doctorat plus généralement
entre 2 et 6 ans de postc des lettres de
recommandation longue comme ça qui ont
publié 10 articles. Je parle de gens qui
ont été toute leur vie premiers de la
classe hein caricaturalement. Et on a on
va en prendre 4 sur 250. Bon, c'est
vraiment vraiment dur quand même. En
plus de ça, ça c'est l'aspect plus
financier. On aura plus d'argent pour
avoir plus de postes et plus de moyens
comme tout le monde. Euh mais il y a
aussi un aspect comment travaillent les
gens, qu'est-ce qu'on attend de nous. Et
là effectivement, je pense que c'est un
peu problématique. C'est-à-dire que euh
il y a quand même de plus en plus l'idée
que ça doit se passer comme dans le
privé, c'est-à-dire financement sur
projet, obligation de résultat,
recherche de budget et cetera. Et
honnêtement maintenant, ceux qui font de
la recherche c'est les tésards quoi. Les
doctorants, vraiment ils font de la
recherche. Euh moi maintenant à 45 ans,
prof, euh je passe plus de temps à faire
des demandes de financement et essayer
de trouver des moyens de financer mes
tésards et mes activités expérimentales
qu'aller faire pour de vrai. Alors
quelque part, c'est normal que il y a
une concurrence. Bon, on peut pas tout
financer, ça je le comprends bien, c'est
c'est pas débile mais le problème c'est
c'est que on n pas augmenté l'argent
mais on a augmenté la manière il était
diversifié. Et donc il faut passer un
temps dingue à demander à tout le monde,
c'est complètement irrationnel, à
évaluer, à être évalué alors que c'est
fondamentalement inévaluable. Euh c'est
inévaluable parce que quand tu veux
faire une révolution, il faut que tu
publies pas pendant quelques années.
Mais si tu publies pas aujourd'hui, tu
vas être considéré comme travaillant
mal. Donc ça c'est aussi une mauvaise
idée et la prise de risque n'est quand
même pas favorisée. Voilà. Donc il y a
quand même une vis et puis il y a
toujours une suspicion, tu vois. Faut
quand même toujours que tu prouves que
tu as fait les choses correctement. par
défaut, on suppose que tu vas pas les
faire correctement. Mais ça c'est c'est
idéologique. C'est qu'on se dit s'il y a
pas de d'évaluation, ils vont mal
travailler. Mais non seulement, je pense
c'est complètement faux. En fait, ça
même un effet exactement inverse. Mais
c'est pas vrai que pour les chercheurs,
on pourrait se dire "Oui, bon encore
eux, c'est des intello, mais non, pas du
tout." Moi, dans un bureau de poste, euh
il y a toujours quelques tiros flanc. Il
y en a aussi dans la recherche, il y a
aussi dans le privé, il y en a partout.
Mais la plupart des gens ont juste envie
que ça se passe bien. Ils n'ont pas
besoin d'avoir le petit chef au-dessus
d'eux qui les surveille avec la carotte
et le bâton. Moi quand je rentre dans
mon bureau de poste, je prends l'exemple
parce que généralement c'est l'exemple
du fonctionnaire branleur. Mais c'est
pas vrai en fait. C'est pas vrai. Je
vois que spontanément s' y a un guichet
où il y a personne, le mec il se lève,
il vient vers moi quand je suis dans la
queue et pour gagner du temps, il me
demande ce que je veux. Ça s'organise
plutôt pas mal tout ça. Mais dans la
recherche, il y a quand même cette
dérive assez technocratique
vers un système évaluation, performance
machin. Et en fait le problème c'est que
du coup comme on est humain donc faible,
bah on se fond dans le moule et et du
coup on se pose plus la question est-ce
que je suis en train de faire des
découvertes mais est-ce que je vais être
bien évalué ? Et tu peux très bien avoir
une carrière brillante en ayant en fait
quasiment pas fait progresser la
connaissance et ça des Jeanpier petit.
Non, mais c'est pour ça que son modèle,
il m'intéresse pas parce que je
travaille au-dessus mais moi le
personnage, il était moins vindicatif et
menaçant et encore d'une façon gentille
hein, euh il me gênera pas. Mais le
problème de ça, c'est que c'est
compliqué parce que après il y a tous
les gens, là je parle pas de lui mais il
y a tous les gens un peu borderline.
Alors moi comme je suis assez open
minded, je reçois 10 mails par jour de
gens qui ont leur modèle leur modèle qui
n'arrivent pas à publier. Mais vous vous
allez me comprendre non mais bon
peut-être que dans le coup il y en a
peut-être que dans le lot il y en a des
bons d'ailleurs mais j'ai pas le temps
quoi.
Comment voit-il l'avenir de la recherche
dans la crise qui approche
l'avenir de la recherche dans la crise ?
alors d'abord si on parle de la crise
mondiale euh je m'en fous de l'avenir de
la recherche. Je veux dire par rapport à
la crise mondiale ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'on survive quoi. Je veux dire c'est
que le monde survive, que le les vivants
survivent et qu'on arrête cette violence
infinie à à l'essence de la vie. En
fait, je pense que ce qu'on fait dans
les abattoirs et cetera, c'est c'est un
crime contre la vie. Mais la vie est un
grand V. C'est contre l'ontologie de la
vie. quand même savoir que 99 % des
lapins qui vivent aujourd'hui en France
n'ont pas connu autre chose qu'un
clapier qui fait deux fois leur taille.
80 % des poules qui vivent aujourd'hui
en France n'ont jamais vu et ne verront
jamais la lumière du jour. C'est c'est
un crime contre la vie en fait qu'on est
en train de perpétrer. Donc pour moi la
priorité c'est ça. Bon après donc c'est
pour ça que vous avez pas bien compris
la question. Après si on parle de la
crise pas au sens crise planétaire
machin mais au sens de la crise voilà où
les choses pourraient aller mieux.
l'avenir de la recherche. Bah je sais
pas moi, pour moi, faut qu'on se batte
pour sauver un modèle alternatif quand
même. Pour moi, c'était un noo de
résistance et ça l'est de moins en
moins. Alors, ça l' encore
ponctuellement, localement. Euh moi par
exemple, souvent le matin, j'aime bien
travailler dans un café. Je travaille
mieux dans un café labo. Donc
généralement, je me lève, je vais au
café, je prends mon ordi et c'est les 3h
de la journée où je fais vraiment de la
recherche en fait où je lis des papiers,
j'ai des idées, je fais des équations
parce que je suis tranquille. Je serais
vraiment pas étonné que dans quelques
années, on me dise "Bah non, tu dois
être au labo, tu es payé pour ça, tu
dois être physiquement présent au labo.
Bah ouais, je travaillerai juste moins
bien en fait." Et donc il y a quand même
une atrophie de la liberté comme ça.
Alors là, on peut dire "Ouais, mais tu
es un privilégié." Mais oui, je suis
carrément un privilégié. Sauf que plutôt
que de dire "Perdez vos privilèges, moi
je préférais qu'on dise de nomler à tout
le monde, quoi." Alors, je dis pas que
tout le monde peut travailler dans un
café, dépend du boulot que tu fais,
évidemment. Mais ce que je veux dire,
c'est que ça aussi c'est l'argument
social qu'on entend tout le temps en
fait de de dire mais il faudrait que eux
aussi en chi en fait. Bah non, ça serait
peut-être mieux que personne n'en chie
quand même quand ça se passe plutôt bien
dans une profession plutôt que de
niveler par le bas et de dire bah eux
aussi on va les [__] dans la merde.
C'estàd peut-être qu'on pourrait
importer au contraire dans les autres
professions ce qu'il y a de bénéfique à
celle-là. jusqu'à maintenant, on
jouissait d'une plus grande liberté que
la plupart des gens et franchement on
l'utilisait bien. Je dis on n'est pas
tous géniaux et cetera, mais globalement
on bosse beaucoup quoi. Moi là, tout à
l'heure je je rentre chez moi, je vais
travailler dans le train mais non stop
quoi. Et ce weekend, je vais passer la
moitié du temps avec mes enfants,
l'autre moitié du temps, je serai devant
l'ordi hein. Donc je veux dire, on bosse
quand même, on on parce qu'on aime ça.
Et donc c'est un peu dommage quoi de
d'oublier cette voilà cette propion
qu'on aussi les gens à faire des belles
choses. On arrive à la fin de de notre
interview. Pas
juste nous.
Euh
la dernière question qu'on pose à tous
les invités, c'est pas une question.
J'aurais dû regarder vos vidéos avant
alors pour mais je l'ai pas fait donc je
vais être surpris.
C'est laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations. Une bouteille à la mer,
quelque chose qui se veut impérissable
ou qui sera disponible peut-être après
toi.
Un conseil, tu as dit c'est ça ? Conseil
pour les jeunes générations.
Moi, je dirais comme ça à chaud sans
réfléchir, je dirais cultivez et
revendiquez et battez-vous pour votre
droit à l'érance. C'est une phrase que
je prends à Isabelle Hebbrar qui est une
belle écrivaine qui est quelqu'un qui
qui marchait dans le désert, tu vois. Et
quand on n jamais marché dans le désert,
on sait pas ce que c'est que la vie en
fait parce que on a la tête dans le
guidon. Moi moi je suis l'archétype du
mec qui était sur l'autoroute quoi. Je
suis n à sur scène lycée pasteur classe
préparatoire matup matsp école
d'ingénieur. J'ai même pas fait de post
doc. J'étais recuté tout de suite comme
chercheur. Bon
je sais pas si je suis devenu un vieux
con he peut-être que oui mais si c'est
pas le cas complètement je pense que je
suis un miraculé quelque part. Non pas
que je me prenne pour un type
extraordinaire, loin de là, mais juste
comme capacité à être un peu en porte
àfau par rapport à soi. Et donc ce que
je dirais vraiment aux jeunes, c'est
quelle que soit la route que vous
empruntez,
laissez-vous le droit de cheminer autour
de la route quoi. Même si c'est pas
rentable, même si vous n'y voyez pas de
retour immédiat, de bénéfices immédiat,
s'il y a pas d'érance. Euh mon ami
Claire qui fait le film My Life là qui
va sortir que je trouve génial. Claire
Deis, je parle euh on lui demande tout
le temps pourquoi tu as pas fait ton
premier film à 25 ans ? Dit parce qu'à
25 ans, je fumais du cheat avec mes
potes. Moi c'est après que j'ai envie de
faire du cinéma. Et c'est peut-être la
plus grande réalisatrice française
aujourd'hui. Je dis pas qu'il faut fumer
du cheat, j'en ai jamais touché. Mais je
veux dire le droit à l'érance, il est
vital et ce monde est en train aussi de
nous le tuer.
Aurélien Barreau, merci. Merci à toi.
[musique]